documentary and that's what the there's
a if you have apple tv
uh which you may it's hard to know um
you may
test deposit um hundreds of people no
but one in every two person has is test
positive for apple tv it doesn't even
i'm so hot yeah i should have i'm taking
them
neil's in a field of velour i'm wearing
a
i sell drugs in the late 80s
somewhere in a pullover velour
shirt but the problem is i'm gonna have
to take my big beautiful arms
oh my god he's he's now it's going over
the head
so i just want people to know that i
wasn't i wasn't
capping am i gonna start saying capping
by the way as an adult
you're not as a not even an adult
middle-aged man
a middle-aged white man you're an adult
i'm not i am a i'm worse than an adult
is
my point i'm a middle-aged white man the
worst age for the worst type of person
so the listeners know
a gray muscle t guns are out i'm gonna
have to go
uh put a different shirt on because
that's right all right i'll do it
[ __ ] it i'll do it do it live
oh okay so i we were talking before
me and bianca have a relationship that
we taught where we talked before
we record and we were talking about
home things and so i've lived here for
10 years
in this house this townhouse and i
but i was never really home at night and
what i realized is
the i knew that the steps down to my
car to the garage my car house as i call
it
were um cold was cold right
i didn't realize so i got curtains to
put up like a
restaurant in new york where they put
curtains for the door
to keep it and uh and
anyhow long story short i measured the
temperature difference
one night it was 70 on the first floor
where the
where the stuff is kitchen living room
keith basement
61. damn so what i realized i have to do
is i
i'm gonna have them build a door and a
wall
at the bottom of the steps which i nev
in 10 years
didn't occur to me to do never occurred
to me to do that
just put a wall in a door so that
there's basically like trap it all
because there's like
seven feet of at the bottom of the steps
the uh the curtain's not doing anything
uh it's not bad but it's just not
you're the kind of rich where whenever
there's an inconvenience
you can just make some like you can just
think of a solution in your head and be
like
i'll build a door did i mention it's
titanium the wall
with gold it's gold-plated um
yes but i like it i'm also cheap
like this all these sleeveless shirts
you should have seen the batch i bought
before the right i didn't want to pay a
lot for this muffler
oh so these these ended up being like 13
gildan i got one that was literally look
like
a f uh fifth grade in gym class the
pennies
remember when like the away team had to
wear like a
garbage i bought garbage
uh sleeveless shirts and they're so
bad they were like satin why because
they were eight dollars each
that's really weird but you're not
you're then you're you're tied about
certain things and not yes
i am tight about i don't like paying a
lot
i don't like feeling ripped off if i
if i overpaid for something i would
never
i would never buy like the off one just
any of that [ __ ] yeah it's like
that's just have you ever been scammed
yeah i mean i'm trying to think yes
like three card monty obviously or no
not three card monty the thing where
they
the guy pretends that he's like i'm
gonna go to the bus station
no that was chappelle mine was uh
it was like a guy he's like i left my
money on top of a thing then another guy
comes and he's like what
but i was so young and i look so poor
they did it on the worst guy
i gave him like a hundred bucks but that
was a lot of money
it was like the day before i moved out
to l.a so what did you feel like after
you got scammed
a fool uh nothing
no good dirty fool um getting scammed is
so embarrassing
it's it's a total violation
it is like no one wants to talk about it
it's a type of trauma we don't really
give a lot of credit to
but being scammed is you feel me what do
you what did they get you for
this guy um i was like
16 and i got a fender bender so i had a
red
nissan sentra but one fender was black
because my dad made me pull pick it from
like the
like the speaking shape yeah seriously
he was like go
find a similar fender in a junkyard
not buying a new vent so it was all
bright cherry red like the desk
and then black and um
i pulled up in a home diva parking lot
this guy's like hey
um i'm working for ford i have paints in
my car
i could i could paint this for you i'll
knock this out right now yeah and he's
like i do and i'm in my 15 year old
six-year-old head was like
my parents would be so proud yeah like
yes i can do this on my own
so i said yeah how much and he's like oh
like 300 bucks i was like
oh no sorry like i'm in high school i
have soccer practice
and he just despite my adult titties
they were very they were fresh
too they're freshly sprung yep so i said
no sorry you know when you're a kid that
you can't scan me for much
and then he just went down 200 no 100 no
i mean
obviously the signs of a [ __ ] scam
and i get him for 60. he's like yeah
we'll do it for 60. i'm like okay he's
like just locked
in there for this is four you're from
ford
you guys are reasonable this is great
and and i this is a nissan so that's
doubly [ __ ] weird but yes so i go
like
and he's like all right yeah i'm gonna
work on it you come in an hour
with the cash lock your door you don't i
don't need the keys or anything you know
i didn't get my keys
it was just the outside of la there's
giant parking lots
where people can like live in a corner
of them yeah no one regulates
it's lawless it's badlands it's lawless
badlands
it's literally mad back so i came back
in an hour
and it looked red and it had this white
wax over he's like all right
in two hours wipe the wax off cool
here's 60 bucks he asked for my number i
give him fake number whatever
oh
and so i was like okay cool wait two
hours before i go home
right now he's on a podcast like and it
turns out the number was fake
i too got scammed and bamboozled so
i tried to wash off that white wax it
never washed off so instead of a black
fender
i had a black fender with like it looked
like trim
like just looked it looked
so confusing and terrible everyone was
like what happened
yeah just i did i was so embarrassed
yep i tried so i had the most well it
was well intended
and i got scammed and it was really
after after that i'm
i was for a few years very leery
leery i heard you wouldn't get drunk and
pass out a party that's how
i got over it there's serious in therapy
um
you should ayahuasca could help you with
that um
the well that the cheap thing
i was thinking uh
about like mine i talked about my niece
no did i talk about my niece no on the
love episode
i said you'd be sad if they died or
something no no my niece
i saw one of my nieces that i hadn't
seen
i spent like very little time with her
right growing up she's like 30.
oh funny your nieces are similar yeah
are like [ __ ]
old women i told you my nephew was out
here on a
on a they're i'm like this is my nephew
and they're like what are you doing in
l.a i'm like
he's a businessman at a conference
and uh but my niece said she was that's
what made me
my thing with my niece was she reminded
me of myself
and then i had the thought i'm
i don't how are we supposed to overcome
family traits like that
um like how like i my whole life is kind
of about that
is overcoming yeah and
like this is how much like me my niece
is i
i you know don't speak to her not ever
but like whatever
i don't have a number um and she said uh
she was getting married the next day and
she said uh
i'm looking forward to being getting
married because i always
dreamt of being a widow wow
which is [ __ ] funny and weird yeah
and that my thought is like well
if that that's a funny thing to say
that's not for everybody no it's a brand
anything
yeah it's very brand new so like how am
i supposed to
make it in show business and in life but
do you know what i mean like
if if that's what i think is funny
then that's not yeah you're not like
mainstream humor no you're never gonna
who's the guy with the puppet
jeff dunham no no no you're not gonna do
these general
generally like no it's not going to be
yeah but you know i'm not going to be
fluffy
no i know it's just an odd it's it's i'm
always trying to like
how can i optimize to be more and then
you realize like you're [ __ ]
so everybody was you're you got
tightness from
the brennans brennan household yeah oh
yeah
yeah everybody's cheap i mean i think
everybody's cheap
for the most part yeah my dad had the
same more the same outfit every weekend
my entire life no one's a big spender in
the fam no
i mean i no no like truly nobody
one of my sisters is in la is in
southern california
she's air being being airbnb
from my nephew in san clemente
like it's all not it's not like persian
but i'm saying it's like
yeah i know you're actually but i'm
saying like family like no cousin you
talk to you get your thing
um but it's
i just don't i don't know i don't i i
like
i want i assume that um every dollar i
make is the last dollar i've made
so i'm you know blake's very cheap too
by the way like he has didn't we
got so much money a million a year we
met at the espys
in 2011 and probably
five years and there was like a gift bag
that we got
and five years later we were both using
the blanket
from and the shaver we're both like no
that's from the asb
you're like oh yeah i don't it's funny
that you
two split bills it's so funny to me yeah
because it's
it's just i don't want to millionaires
for his stupid he eats like a horse not
gonna pay for that it's like when people
order wine and you don't drink the wine
the guy orders nine entrees
he does no he doesn't
bianca we live in a
in an affected world incorporated
girl affected [ __ ] is infected right now
outside is infected i know i used to
read this magazine i think it was called
infection and it was just about
you know disease and viruses in the
world
and if this would be a cover this is the
cover boy it's
kobe's
yeah are you getting
what how was your processing um
i'm really sad it reminds me of when
economies take hits from
war and stuff like that or certain
i love old used to read economies
economies to take kids from war magazine
right
it's just and i like old-timey [ __ ] so i
like reading about
towns that spring up and dry up you know
there's always very specific reasons why
thriving bustling towns and economies
dry up
and so blacks and blacks moving down the
blacks not the blacks this time come on
guys
and uh it just i don't know it's kind of
spooks me out a little bit i don't think
it's going to be
as dramatic as it feels but so many
things are closing so many things
yeah well that's the only thing that
i we can compare it was 2008 the
economic crash
and day to day
my life didn't change at all no it was
mostly housing yes
but it there was a trickle-down effect
to like the whole economy but i
i don't remember
there not being crowds at comedy [ __ ]
like you know what i mean i there wasn't
i didn't feel it this one
i guess i'll feel i don't know i guess
it's i feel
like rich people aren't gonna feel it no
no it's like the depression yeah rich
people like sold a
vacation home yeah but yeah i just
something about that makes me a little
sad but in them
i don't know like are we almost are we
almost done
yeah i i guess it's not to be
insensitive like are we
are aren't we doing the thing aren't we
almost
yeah but you can't come back if
no one will do the simplest [ __ ]
thing
which is wear a mask that's all you got
to do that's all you have to do
[ __ ] wear a mask when you're when
you're i just it's not that hard did you
read that new york article
yeah but i did but i it was it was so it
was the longest new york article
i was like even for the new yorker it
was like coming up this is really the
audiologist
three and a half hours no yes i know i
was like reading it i'm like this is not
good
basically [ __ ] yeah yeah i don't know if
i can get yeah
um it was a litmus test and you failed
it sorry
um but the the
advocacy of masks is massive like there
was
there were it wasn't intentional studies
but there were studies where
people with covet were on flights with
people that uh that they didn't know
like they didn't know they had coveted
they got on flights
and the people that wore masks on the
flights didn't catch it
and the people who didn't wear this is
like in march so people didn't know what
to do right
just simple things of like a b studies
where like they got it they didn't
there's also we needed to study
um there's a lot of studies
out of china where one guy went in a
restaurant
and the air conditioner was blowing a
certain way
and this many people in the restaurant
on this side of it
got infected like 40 people or maybe in
fact
the other day here i know in san jose my
homes i
see it as patrick mahomes i see it as
um uh
don't do too much with your
christmas costume i see that's the
biggest lesson of the whole
[ __ ] you're pushing it guys this is a
blooper you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna surprise everybody
i'm gonna dress like a tree with its own
vacuum system
to make it big it's like dog just
[ __ ] put on a [ __ ] that's a
blooper
your co-workers are gonna die yeah just
cause you had to get
a [ __ ] you had to score
come on my point you gotta go you gotta
because you got to had to get a huge
hospital left
um yeah yeah but no he did
that's what my take away from that is if
i didn't learn anything about cover but
i just learned like yeah that's why you
don't go big
with a copy it's like i dressed up for a
costume party one time and nobody else
was
is that true yeah what did you dress up
as uh
it was like pajamas
and i wore pajamas and nobody else did
and
uh it was in the it was like in the late
90s in a cool group
of people eat everybody why in pajamas
neil
yeah and i was like i it was they said
wear pajamas katie dipole has that
picture from she wrote like the heat and
and ghostbusters
she's and the bunch she's a great writer
uh where she dressed like the
the um horror movie
at a non she at a halloween party she
came in costume
um and nobody else was dressed up and it
was like a drinks
uh wine and cheese situation she said
that's just a picture of her in the back
um those uh age well but you feel
completely
scammed so this is the theme of the
episodes
so all people have to do is wear a mask
and they cannot do it
and as we were saying on before we
started rolling
i believe that if human beings make it
alive make it out alive if they human
beings last another
two thousand years it's not going to be
by much
like we're not it's not we're not we're
not a
he we don't have a huge lead opened up
on
uh being
i wouldn't even say obsolescence i would
say like um
just death of the species we're
we're always this close are you
converting to uh what are those
what are those what are the people that
the end of the world peeps
yeah what's their sect great great
people
uh smart the greys the uh
heavens gay people yeah just i i can't
believe
how [ __ ] wrong that people can't wear
a mask
there's another thing yesterday another
screen first of all i cannot take any
more screaming videos
dude the one in century city mall yeah
where they're like
no it's fault i'm a woman sorry that's
not a good explanation she's just it's
yeah
it's like a rotund woman grabbing at
people
saying you assaulted me he took my phone
coughing
spitting you're afraid i'm like yeah
what this is in blooper reel and that's
what i mean like
how are we gonna make it i don't think
we're gonna make it
if we make it it's not gonna like i said
it's not gonna be by much
take this take this act on the road you
know some one hour specials have a theme
we're going to be out of business i am
worried how this
i just feel like i keep looking at that
1918 i'm like what did they do
they seen it they just wore they just
wore them and didn't go outside when
they
they didn't have parades and they
literally
bonked people in the head yeah they
called them mass slackers and they're
like you're a mass slacker bonk on the
head
go to jail and it was like a group of
like 50 people
and everyone just shun everyone shunned
them
yes and again it's because there aren't
gross symptoms if the symptom was anal
bleeding or
leprosy yeah leprosy eye like some sort
of bleeding out of an
orifice no no one was like ebola
like coughing my fate no one was doing
that so it's just
you're right about that but i also think
everyone was scared
even if they were
there were zombies like they people look
like zombies
i would still think there'd be a group
of people that would be because of the
way
social media and society is now someone
would say like
they're wearing makeup look and then
they'd scoop out
real [ __ ] it's like micelle water but
then again
notice how people treated uh all sorts
of people with aids
it was like three of them very well as i
recall
no it was like get away in the kids that
got it from blood transfusions
yeah can't come to school i don't want
you in your mind
it wouldn't be today it would be they'd
say drug defense years ago
i have proof that he's gay and he he got
it through homosexual contact and it
would just be
conspiracy theories and it's just
so sad even the
trumps i mean we'll get to the trump
stuff but it's
sad it's sad that this is where the
world is
yeah that it's like when i
when i look at the trump thing i almost
want to say to people like
hey i know you're you did support him
but and you hate liberals but you this
is
this you can't think this is good you
have to know that this is bad what he's
doing
yeah no there's people who really are
a mask means you're a [ __ ] wimp
mm-hmm no i'm not i have spoken to a
relative
who's like i'm i'm not wearing a mask
i'm like yeah really
drew got it that's pretty great it's
there it was a good it was a good week
for
he who yeah posted and hosted it
he united supplies
contracted it whatever uh it was good dr
drew was a great one because he's
i don't i used to love doctors i love he
was
everyone's doctor he was so good he was
so good i fell asleep to love line
every night as a kid really great
like a really sound funny enough
balancing um like very clear-eyed
and i think he fell
i think he got a little toot he got a
little tootsie of fame
and it it it's but he was already really
famous
since the 90s since singled out neil he
but he wasn't
uh you know he was faint he was radio
famous it wasn't like
he had the mtv show right that mtv show
wasn't that popular
oh i just assumed it was like dr drew
like everybody knows who you are and you
have a good association to your name
no i mean he it was just local and then
it became
headline news and all that stuff and
celebrity rehab things that were like
yeah like i don't know man how are you a
doctor
yeah are you a doctor a weird thing like
this doesn't seem
like uh you're honoring the hippocratic
oath here but i
just it felt like irresponsible
what he was what he was doing
because it's i don't know it's like you
should
you can control fame it's not you can
just say no i don't want to i just want
to be a dad
and i don't think he should have to
right i'm just saying
it was i'm a doctor that's on tv
and then it became i'm a tv star that
knows about medicine
yeah it's switched it's it's uh it's a
shame because i
i met him one time he's cool uh but the
funny thing is
if you write i don't know how much you
read about the situation but
he was going to get all this [ __ ]
and he was going to get
the vaccine somehow he was getting his
vaccine
and he said the hospital turned him away
because he didn't have his paperwork in
order
and then a week later he contracted it
and i'm like
why were you getting the vaccine because
he's a doctor
of what like tv he is no i think he
stole his rounds yeah
are you sure yeah he still does rounds
not a lot
like he he has his own practice does he
does
hospital he hospitals yes once a week or
something okay
but to me it's just funny how if you're
so against it and
a lot of naysaying even though he did
like
come around he didn't come around to it
yes he had come around i just don't
i'm the opposite of a conspiracy
theorist now i realized
it what i'm saying is i'm i'm i don't
know what to call it but if someone
says there's conspiracy i
automatically side with the
um the legacy
organization that they're saying like i
want double the vaccine
you say there's a conspiracy you thought
the phone is listening to you neil
the phone absolutely i know the phone's
listening to me that's i've seen that
i've that i've seen it's also you type
[ __ ] in
they've i the type shouldn't you know
but like the it's
you know we talked about it it's data
points it's not even it's not listening
with it no i don't know but i
but but like uh alexa was they were
recording everything and then
and then oh sorry we didn't mean to no
for sure but i mean there are people who
i don't i'm not like an eavesdr i don't
think i don't think that
when trying to do this joke where it's
like guys are like
my the feds and it's like
like no like malcolm x had feds
you're trying to get [ __ ] on the gram
like cut it out
it's a big difference in terms of what
you guys are how you're moving
right um i just i have friends that are
there is that i don't always respect
their opinion and they all
talk about
phone listening and it just feels a
little like a guy
wrote a letter and i'm saying i whatever
i that one i've seen
it no it skimmed they scraped [ __ ]
everything like
they did there were hearings like it's
there's a lot of eavesdropping on phones
eavesdropping i know but some people
will see something as an
advertisement and be like i mentioned
that yesterday yeah and give you the
impression that they're listening
when in fact they have so many data
points on you that your association to
so much stuff
makes you predictable which no one wants
to say no
i think both are true they
but at but there's proof of them of
listening oh
sorry right um so
i if you if you're against the
[ __ ] vaccine i i just don't
understand how someone
as arrogant as i at my most arrogant i
never think i know what to do in a state
of 40 million people
in terms of my most arrogance in terms
of hospital beds uh
and a choke point and how many people
can get sick before
they are as you wrote if you they're
turning
in la now if you have a heart attack
and they get to th and the ambulance
gets
there and they try to resuscitate you
and they cannot get you going uh
the hospital you do they say do not call
so
if you don't think you're going to make
it my advice to you is don't call 9-1-1
call 4-1-1 and tell them to get the
trash
to come and pick you up hello sanitation
i'd like to report a thing on the curb
what is it it's going to be me in four
minutes i'm walking out there now and
i'm
dying uh that's like that i don't
so when people say [ __ ] like that
that uh god knew someone's a [ __ ] and
all this stuff
what should they do what should they
it's just a hospital
issue there are only so many i know
only for hospitals yeah it's just
there's only so many icu beds if there
were
infinite icu beds yes don't shut
anything down
but it's there are only so many icu bets
we're at 115 capacity
and uh and so
what how could you think that you know
better
the problem is okay let's try to see
what we
okay i understand that it's annoying and
that it's you don't want
i don't want thanksgiving no i don't
know these peop this is idiotic but what
i'm saying is to try to understand them
they think it's a hoax and not
maybe or let's just say not a hoax but
completely blown
out of your word so if you think there's
times where
we've all thought something like these
people believe this [ __ ] but it's
actually not you know you think you know
better
so what do you do how do you tell people
let's say
how do you tell how would someone tell
yourself actually
you're wrong it's not blown out of
proportion how do you well now you can't
now you can't because they say that is
that that media is that's an antagonized
antagonistic media source and they're
liars and they do it intentionally there
was a stat i saw yesterday
76 of liberals believe
mainstream media and uh either 10
yeah 10 of of conservatives believe
mainstream media
and it's you're like well what do you
believe then and what they believe is
whatever is makes them feel good yeah
the
the masked thing reminded me of you know
how
i mean look everybody knows i've been
[ __ ] a long time
and there were times in the
90s 2000s where you wonder
like if i didn't put a condom on she
wasn't gonna make me
do you know what i mean so it's the
thing that no one talked about it's like
is everybody really all wearing it all
the time
so now with masks you see like oh people
aren't wearing
people are not wearing these [ __ ]
things like it's it's condoms
on the street because no one would admit
to not wearing them
but you couldn't you were a [ __ ]
dirtbag right experiencing the height of
pleasure
but a dirtbag uh and now you see it with
like
people like oh okay like that thing
right
um it i didn't think that many people
were wearing condoms
um my point is uh that
it's a [ __ ]
it's such a massive bummer yeah
it's just like really a profound bummer
of like being stuck
on a on a planet
basically with maniacs
kind of i mean they've a lot of them
have been slowly brainwashed
but a lot of people slowly brainwashed
and but i just don't
get i don't know i mean i i was
thinking we're so fractured in our
country right now how do we get build it
but a lot of countries
stay fractured there's never this
[ __ ] kumbaya
we're all americans most countries do
stay fractured
and then they kind of just they call it
it's just a bad marriage
it's a bad marriage or they split off
yeah and i
actually didn't think it was as bad
as it was in terms of i understand a lot
of
the like human crisis issues we have in
america but i didn't think we would all
not agree on science yeah and a global
pandemic i would
actually have said no most people would
come around yes
but but here's the the funny thing is a
lot of people that were anti-vaxx
two months ago now the vaccine is here
they're like you know what
uh you know i thought about it like yeah
i thought about i did you go up to the
mountain
and go through some [ __ ] uh platonic
thinking you [ __ ]
zero is that did you did you go to the
library and really
look at the [ __ ] epidemiology um
no you just were like oh the thing that
now okay
that and then run toward that okay that
um
it's it's gross now here's my
uh unpopular opinion
so anti-maskers in general
are basically denying science and
are putting their
country men and women they're putting
people at risk right
but my thought is this okay is
anti-maskers
they're no worse than people that eat
meat that have babies
that won't drive electric cars that
travel without offsets because it's just
they're killing people in a different
timeline
okay but that's
a lot of people that you just you're not
the intimate it's most people
most people except me uh
just me and what i'm saying is it's the
same thing of like no i don't know about
that
but i'll have a baby they're going to
come up with an invention to
you have you heard of carbon
sequestration and just all these [ __ ]
things that people think are gonna
happen it's like
dog this shit's bad yeah and you gotta
change this is for everybody you gotta
you can't
pretend that it's not it's just because
you don't drive a pickup truck
you might as well if you have a baby
it's the same
it's in fact babies are way worse than
it's like having
seven pickup trucks i just did some
quick calculations
all on diesel yes all wheel drive you
um so that's an unpopular opinion
what i'm trying to do is advocate for
veganism
in the most abrasive way annoying vegan
yes or just be vegetarian exactly it's
the same thing i'm like oh
mask where no vegans can be very
annoying and you know it
they're they're only annoying in this in
the way that some mascaras are
to [ __ ] people that don't like
wearing masks
like oh
seat belts first became like you had to
wear them
yeah it was like oh i don't remember
that at all oh
it's a [ __ ] huge uh uh imposition
right oh and that and winston would go
wear your seatbelt you'd be like oh
you're [ __ ]
yeah okay i know it's annoying
and it's it's unappealing being vegan
and vegetarian and advocating for it
and it's i have no other than your
just do it for people i'm not i'm not
one of these like the animals i don't
give a [ __ ] about the animals
i'm saying do it for people no for sure
i
i'm talking about something pretty
specific i i fully understand what
you're saying
i'm i do know a lot of especially in the
coasts in the metropolitan
cities where vegans um
are lost people with a lack of
personality and they grab on
to the closest thing which is what they
have one
hell of a personality on on me what they
put in their body for sustenance
and i it's the most uninteresting right
i don't think it's an interesting all i
need to talk about i don't know
i don't get none of it's interesting
conversationally what i'm saying is
what you're doing is pretty much the
same
i think it's just a different a
different group of people that you're
killing right
i do think though most people know
you're an anti-massacre of the future
okay i think uh most people know eating
meats
right you know but they don't get there
aren't yeah it's the condom thing where
ah yeah
yeah fine i'll give you gonna make me do
you're gonna make me put a
tiny moving on so
uh larry king caught it
larry you know how he's gonna get rid of
it he's gonna do an uh
ponderous interview with with covet he's
going to bore the [ __ ] out of kobud
and get it out of its body get it out of
his body by just asking it inane
questions like covet do you miss china
you're from china right do you miss it
you ever go back
you have a check you ever see the old
guys just a horrible interviewer but a
night seemed like
like a nice guy but never nobody ever
said anything interesting on larry
never liked his interviews no i mean he
just never it was
inane it was like hey you want to watch
a celebrity sit next to somebody on an
airplane
and then the guy goes like so your mom
good lady okay okay larry king
barbara walters charlie rose barbara
walters
was would ask uh
like a little was stinging a little bit
she had one
section that was like yeah
charlie rose was um was
on everyone's side uh he was never
he's one of those like well your critics
say it's like yeah
burst barbara wallace would kind of own
her own
judgment charlie rose wanted access more
than anyone i can
think of in in uh
popular in media you mean he just he
wanted
he didn't he wanted yes he wanted the
clout he wanted to have dinner with
these people
as much as he wanted them to interview
them he wanted
that there to be like we're all we did i
say in davos
that [ __ ] he that's what he wanted i
don't know how the jerking off in front
of
uh his staff entered into that uh but he
definitely wanted
um he did what i do which is get in the
shower
but he then he would call people up to
his to his room
staff members okay he would have women
over to like edit
or whatever and then he'd be like i'm
just getting out of the shower
whoops um a lot he did that a lot
uh somebody has that okay i have a
question
that's in the paper i know that but i'm
as a man
paper was the thing that they used to
put out it was the website but they'd
print it out
oh okay um do you when guys
do [ __ ] like that where they'll just
like whip out their dick
does a guy has that had to have worked
for a guy to do it or does a guy just
have a fantasy like
this would be amazing if this worked
it's like chicken or the egg did it i
mean i think it
probably works i think it's like gets
the party going
but my thing is i don't even know
like if i'm like gonna clearly have sex
with somebody even if
let's say it's the tenth time i've had
sex with them there are women that make
to a tenth
business wow and uh they get afraid they
get a free
final boss they get a freebie
and i don't if they go to the bathroom
i don't do i don't like take my
underwear off
and wait for them naked even in bed i
wouldn't i don't like doing that
no you don't like a surprise no i just
it's also like they get in and they
kick and my like you know what i mean
like it's like let's just
i don't want to surprise thank you even
the people that want to
[ __ ] me i don't want to surprise them no
so
you've got to think pretty highly of
yourself to be like
she wants me to take it out now i have
been told
by someone who worked in in like
sexual uh psychopathy for lack of a
better word
that guys who do it like at the bus stop
oh yeah think that it's gonna lead
somewhere dude that happened to me i'm
like
oh my god this is where you when you're
with the bumper
that's how you got the fender i was in
high school it was i
had a backpack on and i think soccer
cleats on and the guy is just jerking
off the bus stops my mom
loves talking about how when she was a
little girl there were
people there were people flashing her
all the time
she brings it up every time she talks
about it i don't know it's just a
it's like one of her indelible memories
is dudes
uh flashing school girls i
men are infinitely more creepy when
you're underage
interesting they i've never been hit on
more in my life
than when i was underage clearly with a
backpack
clearly not walking home punks you need
a ride
a million do you need a ride no one asks
me if i need a ride
so rude but no no then you go can you
get me an uber
lux no people need a ride
hey what time is do you know excuse me
do you know what time it is
dick out like uh it's time to suck your
dick
i'm not mistaken and this is around to
high school i just like
and that's so
ups it's like the same from the people
who aren't going to make it
it's the same it's all the same [ __ ]
thing that you don't
know i've no i just never
liked young women meaning
i i when i was 20 yeah like i was
always more attracted to like 30 year
olds right uh i guess it's because i'm
an old soul
oh how that's changed yes now the
table's returned
it's payback time young young [ __ ]
no but even my even like on the apps
i'll i've slid the thing
older because i'm like i can't date a
[ __ ] 23 it's impossible
where is it at now 29 yeah we're still
here
don't be ridiculous um so
dudes are just creepy and i don't think
people realize how
um how numb
women get to it yeah i'm just like okay
yeah okay you're just a [ __ ] creep
yeah that's one of those things where if
i'm surprised that women said anything
about cat calling
when there's that and i'm that's not
like i was a
cute girl little girl i don't think
that's
yeah it's a rare situation no i don't
think it but what i'm saying is
that's that i think you could have not
like you could have gotten guys more on
your side but
there was the equivocation of of uh
well i get you know i remember che said
some
got in trouble for saying like i get
recognized a lot
wow and it was really yeah
and uh that's equating it's a cat
calling but
if it if it had been like jerking off
that's where
i don't i think most guys are like yo
but [ __ ] no you can't jerk off dude
i think it's a combination of you know
when there's a grandparent
and you know they've seen some [ __ ] but
they don't even tell you
and then the one thing they tell you by
the shake
yeah and then when they do tell you
something you're like yeah right
like that sounds too far-fetched i just
don't think people believe that
your face even is like what not i mean i
don't believe you don't believe
yeah i mean it sounds a little bit like
and i think some people would say
you know oh maybe you were maybe there
let's let's find the
filters that make it a really specific i
was with friends
and then that guy also did it to
somebody else the next day
in the same neighborhood it's just like
people are like
predators yeah i mean yeah we're like
animals
so i don't see i mean even i wat i mean
i love my animal dogs
all we all we do as as human nature all
we do
are try to eat babies all the meat we
eat is young
and so it's not a far cry it's not a
far-fetched cows aren't young
chickens aren't young right no ev every
animal i mean they're not only under the
[ __ ] now we're just [ __ ] we need a
year and a half we're like get in
hurry up get fully grown so i can eat
most of them aren't like for example a
fully grown lamb is like mutton no one
wants to eat that anymore you know
you eat young things
it's already in a jamaican accent yeah
um but yeah no i just it's like
human nature to go after young i just
don't think guys believe
how creepy guys can be well it's that
thing that i brought up
on the pocket somebody got upset about
like fertility
year old girls are for they're just it
feels like
the best shot at i think that's like the
animal part
you know what i don't think i think it's
that
sh i she's not old enough old enough to
know that i'm
a [ __ ] creature yeah so and when
you're young like let's be honest
a guy honking at you when you're 14 and
feeling awkward is like
a little flattering it's kind of scary
but it's like this guy like
you know it's this new dining room yeah
yeah so
i think never leaves even when you are
in love with them
so yeah no i think they can get away
with more [ __ ] i don't know um
yeah i don't know uh speak for your
people
what we were how we even got there we
were talking about larry king and then
charlotte no then charlie road yeah
charlie rose was a big
wanted he he liked going like i spoke to
bill last week
about bill gates bill was here and
he liked knowing like like a bad
character
networking thing of like uh we're all in
the same club aren't we
it's like no clout chasing yeah that was
before
there was a word for it um so thank you
internet
you did it again cloud chasing if you do
nothing else internet you were worth it
for coming up with the term clout
chasing
on oh um takes care of covid it's oh no
there's a this is funny
what so you know they're old people have
to sign up
they have to like schedule their
vaccines but
but they're making it but in a lot of
places it's on an app
which is like guys the worst it's like
where there's an aids vaccine in women's
vaginas
you're never gonna you don't wanna go
there you don't understand it
but gay men if you can get it that's
it's worse than that because at least
you can understand a woman's vagina
all people do not understand technology
um
and uh it's like we're gonna there's a
cancer but you gotta run this marathon
we have we have the vaccine but you
gotta run this
there's a there's a technological
ignorance pandemic going on with old
people and somehow we thought that
[ __ ] made me laugh
every state like that no it's a few but
it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's just hilarious that they didn't
think like what are you talking about
like this person is
95 years old how the
uh it if they did forwarded emails that
could work because all people love
afforded him
uh trump pressuring people for votes in
georgia
he's so uh did you try to listen to him
oh i did it's
[ __ ] bearable his opening monologue
was i measured it at 12 minutes and it's
just
[ __ ] nonsense the fact that they've
allowed
this to happen i mean they they had no
choice but
i mean he's so
i couldn't believe how the
dynamic that everyone's led it got to
it's like when
i have an aunt that works as a nurse and
a guy cut his finger
on a toilet in a junkyard he's a
construction worker and by the time he
came into the er sounds like a made-up
story
no i know it was he said it was white
and
half of it was bone and they're like you
didn't think to come in before
half your pinky was born and he just was
like
who's that he's that's trump trump it's
gotten so bad but people on the phone
were like
uh no but here so i mean i'm not like
i'm afraid
they're afraid uh empathize here's the
position they're in
trump is wildly popular it's true that
with voters yeah so that's the problem
they're basically held captive
there's nothing if they if they want to
be republicans
especially elected if they want to be
re-elected
they can only they have to basically
be suicidal about it and be like i don't
care if you vote me out
this guy's [ __ ] wrong this guy's
wrong and only like mitt romney can
because he doesn't
yeah he doesn't like trump doesn't do
that and the utah
republicans are not gonna like yeah like
he's an institution and
and um like i can't i think trump won
but i don't whatever so there are a few
people that can get away with it
republicans but most of them are held
captive and it's like
dude when it's like party uh country
over party
it's country over self more than
anything it's in order for them
to go against him to go against trump
they're gonna get harassed
they're and they're gonna get primaried
they're gonna it's just gonna be a huge
it's a giant
uh their life will just be worse
um so i understand where they're coming
from but
you gotta draw the line [ __ ]
somewhere
i don't understand i i get i just feel
like the risk
is a little bit lesson for them
after the election because there are a
lot of there are people who are just
like
okay he won he lost yeah and accepting
it there are some people who aren't
but it it does dwindle as a the
more information comes out as a court
people who are far right
true trump supporters even some are like
okay i mean
it's probably not gonna happen so but i
don't see the
the ratio of that his his popularity is
not going down but the
idea that we can turn it around i think
the support for that's going down but i
don't see republicans
adjusting like oh good like the abusive
father's gone you know they're not just
at some point you have to just condemn
it but they
but they're not even though he's not
going to be president that's what they
but they're
he might be president in 2024 and
they will definitely he will tweet
against them
and why in the next four years he's
gonna tweet against them he's gonna
tweet against everybody
the whole i mean yeah it's well they
they don't realize like he
just it's all he tweeted against the
[ __ ] governor of atlanta
a governor of georgia who he who's been
a huge supporter of his
and who went on tv today and literally
kissed his ass
and they asked him about it and he's
like i asked for an audit
i asked for an audit three times
yeah and it's i it's every they're
they're in an abusive relationship yes
they have it's like the thing i was
saying it could be like a
month ago where it's like we need a
restraining order seriously
and i don't and they're in a it's
this is what i was trying to say
when all the ellen and all that stuff
was happening this is what happens
when someone has a ton of power and it's
based on their popularity
yeah um is
everyone that works around them is so
they have so much power and you get
reflected glory from it it's like people
wear like
you know production shirts or like they
have credentials yeah like or you go to
you go to uh thanksgiving
we used to when you used to go home for
thanksgiving and people go hey what's
so-and-so
whatever you work i never understood why
people wanted to work on a good movie
versus a bad movie
it's like you want to work 14 hours on a
coen brothers movie or eight hours on a
dating game show i'd be like [ __ ] get
me on the dating with the
same money the [ __ ] do i care yeah but
it's the perspective but it's the
prestige of
like what's what are the cohen brothers
like people are dying to know
um uh and that's what happens
the the reflected glory of being around
the white house
being around the president being it's
better than not
yeah and once you've gotten a tootski of
it
yeah once you get it yeah the two little
little uh coke pinky uh
once you get a tootsie it's like that's
dr drew and fame it's like yeah do
i you just i don't know you just it's
insidious
and and so these people are stuck in a
museum we had a joke on on me and b mean
bajan
the great editor of chappelle show who's
not speaking to me right now but
why it's a long story um
uh when sometimes dave would come to
editing with like
most deaf or somebody like they were
whatever and he'd be like hey
show uh show mo such-and-such and i'd be
like i haven't even started that yet
and he'd be like oh all right like kind
of disappointing them
so it became a thing where i'd go like
get most deaths from calamari
we don't serve calamari be like get him
some [ __ ] calamari
uh but that's in a way what all those
the handlers they're in the position
where
i wasn't like afraid of dave yet but i'm
saying it became a joke but
but where they just have to appease if
he's feed this guy
because he's so [ __ ] popular with
voters that he can get
three uh supreme court justices on and
[ __ ] like that which is
powerful it's a real nice incentive
like i don't think anyone's gotten three
uh supreme court
justices like that's a [ __ ] so if you
have to
live in his weird truman show sometimes
yeah [ __ ] it
where do i eat what do i this is the big
spoonful of [ __ ]
how many how many do you think actually
like that can't stand it
uh i don't i don't i don't think that
they can't
stand up i think you just end up in a
place of like
this guy's [ __ ] crazy
and it's good for the party and it's
good for my ideology and it's
i like winning that's what most of it
comes down to is like i just they just
like winning
um because again i've never
i've never gotten an abortion i like it
like i want it legal
right i don't know because i guess it's
good
you know what i mean like i just i don't
it's where i want women women like it
i like women you know like i don't
there's a
like reproductive fruit that should get
there have been a lot of comics lately
talking about how
abortion louis did a joke about abortion
that was like sympathetic to abortion
uh anti-abortion people and i've heard
like three or four
comics voice the same thing
i said to gerard on the phone like 10
years ago
abortion is kind of killing kind of a
baby
which is what it is and then burr did a
thing
i've heard rocks and some [ __ ] on the
butt like everything kind of killing
kind of being
good kind of killing i don't
it's just killing a baby this is rough
um even if it's kind of killing kind of
a baby
um the uh anyhow
you just there's things that they just
want to win
and so it's worth
you know it's like lebron gets to have
his friends on the plane
and or or they said james harden gets to
go to vegas and then
when he comes back he scores [ __ ] 43
points
nine rebounds and eight assists yeah
yeah it's like
i don't think it's right i don't think
it's right
but ah i think that's how they feel it's
like that's the power
of celebrity popularity it's just
okay you're the boss yeah and you just
[ __ ] and then they all try to act out
loyalty
in the face of they know it doesn't make
sense i was listening to franken's
podcast
and there one of the lawyers said
kept saying that that when they were
trying to
get like one of the suits about
about the how the count wasn't fair and
certain
and they kept saying like
no no trump uh observers were allowed in
and and the judge kept feeling like wait
it says here
that there were three of each party and
but the guy was told by giuliani and
trump
to say there were none so he kept saying
there were none and the
and the and the judge was like wait so
there
were there any republican observers in
the room and he said
there was a non-zero amount wow
it's like [ __ ] crazy world okay where
you say a non-zero amount
it's like you sound you literally look
like the the head
of the georgia voting implementation
manager whatever that guy well that
guy's
like trying to speak sense into these
people like
i then what he was going over it like
step by step
yeah he was like okay yeah we're gonna
one guy called another guy like he's
into like who
called [ __ ] it's like it's like cheaters
but going like i was here and then i
went here there's video of it
it's it reminded me of that stage in a
uh just a [ __ ] relationship where the
person constantly acts out constantly
feels insecure constantly needs
reassurance
and there's a small period where you're
gonna oblige no i i pulled over because
i got a phone call
that's why this is the truth in that
relationship this is the proof i swear
it wasn't
anything that's ruffling your [ __ ] it
like
triggering you and that is such a
short-lived period because eventually
like
i i'm not gonna expect you i'm not gonna
say to you because you don't [ __ ]
care and it's not about
you understanding it just takes so much
out that guy
i felt so well it's you're trying to
negotiate with a crazy person right and
you're like
these are the hoops you have to jump
through to and then they go like what
about that and it's like i told you
this it makes you crazy yeah but i don't
think you said it like that
yes i [ __ ] did you're not listening
yes and okay it's just the whole thing i
felt so bad for that guy
because he at so i was watching it on
fox news
and then they go to the head of trump's
campaign
i don't know like a fat-headed guy and
he couldn't he couldn't he's like no he
said some good things
but he didn't say why the
uh like why pelosi was like made an
off-handed
comment about like yeah i mean it was
there's somebody
if the press had covered hunter biden
better
it's always something then they wouldn't
have to do like the [ __ ] are you talking
about
he's like i wish this happened uh
december 4th
yeah like it's nonsense i okay um
i don't know uh
it's bad though no yeah it's not good
that's what i'm saying like if we can
make it through this
the whole thing is like how do we
survive any of this
how do we survive the civil war how do
we survive the 60 martin luther king and
bobby kennedy and jfk were shot within
six years of each other
like what the [ __ ] yeah how did
how was how were was faith restored
in this country well that was like it
wasn't no well it depends on no but it
was it really
it's all and then watergate and then and
then then it's like
this just makes watergate look like yes
but absolute distress of government
and that if trump is a lie it's
justified he's fighting for it
there's just ways to spin it and you
can't
dissuade people from it um
sad um all caps
sad moving on georgia senate
this will air tomorrow we're live
john ossoff god godspeed skinny if
if that skinny [ __ ] skinny white
kid can
win in georgia anybody can there
you know what i thought about all of our
political ads that were dominating ended
for everybody else
two months ago that [ __ ] is still going
in georgia the whole time they've had
no break of nonsense on the radio
on tv after tomorrow it's back to
strip clubs and local car dealerships
varsity hot dogs
um yeah the uh i hope i hope
those guys win i really if those guys
win
what do you think's gonna happen i think
it's gonna be split
i think one of them win and one won't
well duh what do you mean
no i think i'm talking about acif and uh
the black dude oh yeah the
liberals uh i think they're gonna split
uh but let's say it goes to a liberal
majority
senate no no it's not i'm saying it
won't i
i i think they're gonna if it goes to a
liberal
if it becomes a liberal majority senate
the good news for conservatives i
promise you liberals will [ __ ] it up
that's the good news i i promise i'm
sorry
under no circumstances will they as they
say miss an opportunity to miss an
opportunity
they will they will absolutely deliver
it on
garbled legislation and somebody will
sit out
and then this wing will hold hostages
they will [ __ ] it up so that's good news
and then and biden will probably
do alert by the way his
press conferences now he can't
even get one sentence right in some of
these
i think he needs to wear sunglasses all
the time by the way he looks good his
eyes are too small
when's outside um he uh
yeah he it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's hilarious because it's i mean yeah
it's
the good thing is that um we're social
distancing
so he doesn't really need to do as many
live things as he needs
and fatal no he's doing them without
he's doing those distance ones he's
doing kind of every day
he did one the other day where he [ __ ]
up every sentence he said he would god
hey kyle don have you seen kyle
dunnigan's [ __ ] oh my
kyle dunning kyle donegan's joe biden is
so goddamn
it is the uh
year's it's like new year's wishes
instagram kyle donaghy
uh on the the first second row
joe biden looking [ __ ] blue
background that's right
joy beard wish you a congratulations on
your face space
launcher a big deal man not not facebook
facex space sex launch
uh cool sorry who is this
joey b former vice principal under
barack toboggans come on man
president erect oh cool
sorry i'm distracted with kurt cover 19.
kids will do that to you uh i think you
think of my son ax
f-12 19
is different and very much not very good
we'll take care of them all
man hey wait a minute i got to
congratulate but the man makes me laugh
at one point it goes corn pop was a it
was a good cop
or no he said count chocolate was a good
cop [ __ ]
killed me i count chocolate was a good
cop man
i you know what i feel like once he got
elected everyone's just like okay i
don't want to look at you anymore
we knew we knew but now we have to go
with
just wait for conway to take over so she
can get thrown out of office for four
years
that's what's gonna happen let's do it
it's gonna be a race between why people
vote around racism or sexism
um anyhow
pelosi and uh mitch got graffitied
um yeah and uh which all i ask is
if you're going to do it when you don't
like the legislation you have to do it
when you do like it
so if they do something good you need to
give them a thumbs up emoji
and instead of a pig head do a whole
pig roast and really blow it out guys
it to what you know to be easy okay
and ilaria all right ellaria
baldwin yeah okay that's how it's
pronounced
yes um i have
please some thoughts i'm not let me just
say that i think alec baldwin's
really talented cool um
i like him i don't hear great personal
things
but i i know he's very talented
um and uh so that's good
so hopefully if he sees this that will
assuage his
he uh saw one of my tweets one time and
snapped at me
like eight years ago um so uh
anyhow i hope so
here's my question
what who got hurt and what are the
charges
um with hilaria different
thing neil different char different
it's not a criminal it's a it's uh
what's the
social right what's the is it is this a
felony because people are acting like
it's a felony no
not a litter but a social media felony
um this is not a social media felony but
this is
this could be a felony but they'll give
it's a misdemeanor it's gonna
it should be a misdemeanor to me it is
the the reason why it's a little more
than a misdemeanor
is uh
it's just so cringy when things are so
cringey it's just like go away yeah why
did you
do this too i'm not saying that it's uh
it's it's it's it's
dolezalian in that well dole is all
what looks like [ __ ] uh sojourner
truth compared to [ __ ]
hell are you but you were not into the
uh the the what's her name
[ __ ] shawnee she's got not when she
did the jamaican
what was her damn name adele
you were like nah adele no don't worry
yeah that wasn't that was a misdemeanor
that was misdemeanor yeah okay
that was what was it absolutely um this
went on for so long and she was just
like
amy's funny and family you know it just
feels real i think it's a white cry for
help that
i don't think people are being
empathetic to white people the the uh
the wasteland that they that white
people culturally live in that we're
taking on other people's cultures
as our own um look at me dressing like
dressing like a puerto rican today um
in like there's a lot of latin people
where i'm from
because san jose there's a lot of yeah
and
i think you're gonna say
what's canals there the panama yeah
there you go
take that [ __ ] somewhere else
so a lot of girls
because they're a lot of north la
mexicans
and they're lighter and a lot of girls a
lot of white girls
would yeah court the the mexicano
yeah the word cortez's and the socks
well cortez is you know everybody worker
doesn't sound like but the dark
yep chola cholita like eyebrows
hard lip liner gloss like
uh la like ellie looks uh
you know gel
um i did i've done a black scent in my
time
and not again i'm serious but being
honest like man homeboy
no but you know i'd slip into it
probably
anyhow brennan so that that's my
excuses i was 19. okay the the teenage
girls they're [ __ ] like
16 they that's a cool
local dominant culture like it's some of
its [ __ ] group dynamics
100 this [ __ ] is
nonsense it's it's just not
by the way somebody told me a lot like
a year or two ago they're like i know
her when she was hillary
no yeah and i didn't know we should have
broke this i know i didn't i cause i
didn't
i don't care i knew her when she was
hillary yeah hilary thomas
yes someone did a deep dive because i
also think i also think in your defense
uh misdemeanors become felonies and
coveted because everyone's so [ __ ]
bored
it's kurt metzger who is who is on that
kyle dunnigan clip
they do a uh fake podcast about
men who love women called [ __ ] and uh
metzger calls it uh flop it's a cultural
flop
so this is one of those things where
sometimes if in soccer games you'll see
it
and in basketball american basketball
you'll see it
when it's two european dudes they'll
both flop oh yeah
that's what this was to me she flopped
and then the internet flopped
like none of you no one cares how did
the internet flop
i'm get i did a deep d i'm investigating
what are you investigating lady said she
was [ __ ]
lied people lie all the time
she responded to that stuff she's not
like she's like i lied and then people
like
you knew she lied she had to respond
because people were like
yeah and she said she lied yeah no she
said
i feel like it died down once that
happened though yeah but that's why i
was saying like
it's up right no it's just a dumb it's a
it's a
weird it's [ __ ] weird that when
things are weird
we get a little obsessed we do i
uh yes i like to think that i'm weaning
myself from it
some things work some don't uh
i but i find rarely is er
is the sizzle
worth worthy of the steak this is not
much of a steak freeze
this is not much mistake you could have
thrown it in there yeah that was pretty
good
um yeah i mean look um
first you want me to do it count
chocolate was a good cop um
so i just don't think
anything happened you know what it's
this is this is when you're a kid
and there's a little bit of a mystery
and most of the time in life
there's not an active mystery and you're
like oh my god wait let's go buy the
house
yeah and then you go but then it's oh
it's the old man get a [ __ ] get a job
it's like i stopped doing that [ __ ] as
soon as i got a job right but there is a
thrill and now covid a lot of people
don't have jobs
yeah so i just feel like these little
things that kind of would have made a
you know flashlight i don't disagree
what i will say is this
thing of uh
it's like these people the it's a
sleuth it's like no it's a [ __ ]
busybody snitch
is what it is it's not the what and now
what
now how is the world changed at all no
one was being hurt by it
and no one was being helped by it it's a
[ __ ] weird quirk it's like
chet hayes yeah ch for supporting chet
hank
by the way did i tell you that chet
hanks uh someone i know went
to the prom with him wow and she was one
of
two dates that he brought this kid's
been out of this kitchen
and he did the patchway he did the whole
thing ew
but then he was then he's in my show i'm
watching your honor which actually got
very good by the way
i know i keep hearing that it's [ __ ]
amazing
he's and the whole time i'm like doesn't
that look like that chatter hangs
is he any good he probably is right he's
fine he has a
really basic role all right or he's like
a scared come on
he's a scared gun so he's like oh all
right yeah it's like very big and he
he was cool to do a white accent oh yeah
no no whatever
yeah uh it's the it's just this odd
thing of
in the mid 2000s stop snitching to now
it's
snitch all the time in every
circumstance
one no but okay does dole is all
we were all in you brought bought her
art and gave it to chris roberts because
it's so funny
it's funny it's interesting that's funny
that's a funny use of rachel
what i'm saying the rest of it no what
i'm saying is this is just some
busy body [ __ ] use it rachel
it's the best way to use her best um if
she
can't if she won't adopt you then buy
her art
um why aren't you on the fun training
on this because it's just because it's
to
a white culture it's also a black how
did no it's wow
latina the things these will work but
it's a spaniard latinx but she ain't
she's not saying i'm chilean or
guatemala
i can't it's all mexican to the whites
um it's also it is spanish if you're
european
uh she just it's like ren is easy i
wasn't mad at rena's easy
no i just was like i yeah but when when
i saw when rana's easy did it
i'm dying up here or now i'm dying up
here what's the one this is this is not
happening
and uh jfl i
[ __ ] understood his
i understood where i told him and he
ended up using it i don't know if he
used it
where i said some it was one of those
things where you saw the lie
and you had 10 seconds to correct it i'm
sure he
and once you were out of that window it
would have been
weird to go back and be like you know
what
remember how i told bobby that i was in
911
i lied or something yeah it was just
been a bit
i don't think that it's sim i don't know
what you mean way more innocent
this is just some weird climber [ __ ]
well this is what i heard yep that
i guess you worked at a restaurant or
something and
the girls picked up he had an affinity
for latina girls
and she is already on her own
as latin culture enthusiast salsa
dancing
yeah like probably has some level of
spanish going on
like whatever so hammed it up a little
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and then i
my thing is there's a lot of famous by
the way you love it in a romantic comedy
she does this in a romantic comedy you
every woman in america is spending
fifteen dollars
but in a romantic comedy she'd be like
it'd be like [ __ ] like she would have
it really
you guys the scolds take the
second act fun out of it where she gets
caught this is never gonna be fun
enough romantic comedy is hilarious
where they go you lied to me
i only lied because i liked you okay but
rana's easy didn't go on
a [ __ ] 911 cover right but i'm saying
yes you know what i mean like she's
going on hola every time she's a kid her
kids are named like leonardo
antonia yeah like i heard this rosalie
makes them go to home depot every day
and try to
scrounge jobs and the home depots are
never they're one on 14th street
it's just weird to there's no drive
there's a parking lot for them to
solicit uh traffic the only reason why
i find it to be weird is because there's
plenty of people who are
married and spouses of famous people and
you don't know their [ __ ] name
and that feels like that's something
some weird climber [ __ ]
right and it but it felt like on this
like ilaria
it's not like she grew up in
kalamazoo if you grew up in boston it
was like a well to do and her parents
i guess i was gonna tell you what my
spanish name was in spanish class what
was it
it was naruto
wait your name was naruto and santa
claus it was they just there's no neil
inspired yeah yeah
so they just feel like naruto which is
so oh my god
and it's also not the least spanish noun
it just sounds like a spanish it sounds
like
naruto get over here like get in here
naruto when you're being bad you're
naruto yeah i'm
not but i think it could it could really
help things will
yeah naruto will just google nardo
and it's um meanwhile he's still trying
to figure out kyle donegan
um nardo he had no problem with um
so hilary baldwin
i'm issuing a double technical
tr well i'm issuing a triple double i
don't know what that means double
technical
flagrant internet is this flagrant
uh no it's it's it's a flagrant
one you stay in the game but it's
offsetting tech it's offsetting free
throws
um yeah that sounds good hilaria you're
crazy
hillary and internet you're a [ __ ]
so that's my ruling that's funny um
uh well argentina just legalized
abortion
yeah no that wasn't i know that didn't
we look it up on here where it's legal
yeah we did no and it's not that many
places
no it's not even it's not legal in
ireland they have to go to london
uh it's not really legal in south
america
um they're sending cocaine up worse than
abortion knives um
it's back and forth uh where's abortion
legal
world map um this whale's flailing right
now all right
green i like that green is for go ahead
and get an abortion
they don't like abortion near the
equator what is it without restriction
as to reason like
you need uh meaning you don't need to
say i was raped or
uh incested but did i ever say doug
stanhope's bid on this
it's such an amazing bit so he did a bit
probably 15 years ago that
every life is precious right yeah and
then they say
unless the woman is a victim of
rape and then it's not precious
because the dad was a dick stupid
that's the only difference it's like so
that's not nugs the dad was an [ __ ]
it's not it's not if accidental
pregnancy
precious accidental pregnancy from rape
because the dad was a dick and the woman
didn't want to be there
not precious kill it um
kill it with you got the green light to
kill it uh
it's funny you don't like abortion near
the
equator they don't like it near the
equator they really they sure don't
india uh thailand wow mexico
malaysia being real catholics and it's
also
all central and south america is about
catholicism you know that
santa maria uh all this is about
religion
yeah all of it and all types
the enlightenment the upper part is
about the alignment well you'll put some
um
arrows in there so good uh
congratulations argentina
attaboy attaboy kind of killing kind of
babies nashville bomber
moving on
i mean yeah but that's what happens when
dumb
in order for america to have civil
liberties anywhere to have civil
liberties right
sybil i call them civil liberties a
civil shepherd um
is carl hart the guy who wrote the book
that's coming out in a week oh yeah i'm
gonna
have him on here um
i was thinking about his stuff and he's
basically saying like
legalize legalize everything right and
the my only argument against it is there
are people
that and it's not a very it's not a
passionate argument but there are people
that cannot
handle uh open
drug use there are people that can't
handle open alcohol that's
why 90 000 people a year are killed by
alcohol
in america um but that's like
grandfathered in we just assume you
can't
there are certain people who can't
uh they don't they have too many
comorbidities
to live in a world without masks you
know what i mean like
um people are too soft-headed
for to
to discern what's a conspiracy and
what's not the guy blew up the
18 t because he it was part of a 5g dude
thing and and in order for
us to have free speech you can't have
two free speech because you've got dumb
people listening
i don't know how to reconcile yeah it's
like i don't it's you want free speech
but then people are too dumb to discern
what's true and what's false
and you go well you you give them the
credit they don't deserve the credit
they cannot [ __ ] discern what's true
and what's false
like i think i could live in a world
with
open heroin and open cocaine and open
like i think i could
handle it because i'm i like i'm rigid
i'm disciplined i can take some and
take a night off um
so that's what i worry about with
it's like the alex jones argument like
well you should
free free speech should be absolutely
free
but and let people decide and then you
get these people are too credulous
yeah they cannot and you go well who's
going to control it
and and then you go i don't know no
that's not the end
the end is i don't know who controls it
maybe naruto
nardo might naruto get in here um
uh so i need to get in touch with narnia
i'm gonna talk with you guys i'm doing a
documentary called finding narnia
um so yeah i don't i
that that's another thing where if
america may if we make it it's
not going to be by much if people can't
not get soup headed
about you know immediately
it's it's it's a [ __ ] bummer it's
i'm like with drugs and you i that's me
with confusing theories because i mean
i've said it a bunch but
i just growing up it was just funny to
believe in aliens and
listen to coast to coast and get scared
and i mean when i
tell you the most innocuous dabbling
into like
oh shoot like roswell you know
nonsense i was always the person being
like oh my god are they real blah blah
and now i have friends
who have aged
into conspiracy theories that are like
you know five
they're l like everything but i'm like
literally wait i don't take it i
can't i don't think they're not
responsible enough
or intelligent enough to
discern they cannot discern
they can't so weird to me and they're
just they're just
dull they're dull-headed people and i'm
like
just literally you don't even need to
discern you don't even need to be smart
this isn't even back in the day
just google it literally google it and
that could take away
a lot of the burden of discernment
you know okay oh this infographic seems
convincing
i see it on instagram just google it
the benefit of the doubt um
not sure no no i no longer i'm sure
about
giving anyone the benefit but it starts
feeling like when i have friends telling
me about 5g [ __ ]
and i'm like wait
you and then it's like they're like you
don't
think that like you do think that yeah
it's the spider-man spider-man
it's so it's it's it's i don't know how
to
if you think you are the one with the
knowledge
and i am the ignorant run and i think
you are the ignorant one
i'm the one with the real knowledge how
do we get right how do you square that
and i don't that's that's where
i believe in like the electoral college
is wrong and all that stuff and then i
look at the voters and i'm like um
but then it's their elitist they have
their mind okay
i like their i i don't know i like their
biases better
yeah i i did okay
moving on brexit finalized
congratulations everybody i never
understood it
congratulations brexit uh you were
confusing from the beginning
and i still don't know what happened
although i the things i do know is that
it was based on
racism and uh budget [ __ ] don't look it
up will there's no point
um the funny you know a lot of people
were saying that
yeah my grandfather my grandmother voted
for brexit and then
died a month later well like they died
was the the the the
less contact they had with
continental europeans and by that they
mean [ __ ]
africans foreigners yeah um the more
likely they were to vote
based on right like it was all farmers
voting of course to leave
but it's like it's there's a lot of
there's it's africans it's indians it's
like eastern bloc
it's so it's they have [ __ ] themselves
so royally because
they don't produce that much on that
island
and they don't they actually there's a
reason why they were a kingdom is
because
i it's a lot of it was just service
it they they're getting rid of a lot of
nurses and [ __ ] like that like it's less
about production i think
i don't mean about production it's just
they don't produce
like just agriculture just there
yeah they couldn't they tried to get
white people to pick the strawberries
and they were like
uh me fingies um they yeah like they
it's
they're they're soft and
again it's the same problem it's these
two for it's like
clashes of civilizations
between uh
accepted wisdom and then this sort of
outsider freedom fighter and
it's just gonna the same it's gonna be
the same fight for 30 [ __ ] years
i'm gonna be the same fight until i die
until one of them finally comes and
shoots me in the head
and with an assault yes yeah it's just
the same it's the [ __ ] same thing
over every single
argument now will come to that well you
know it's funny now europe
to punish london wants to because the
thing is english people are
one of the most traveled in all of
europe because no one wants to be in
england for the summer
so they're gonna charge them
higher high fees to get a visa to come
into their country
great everybody on the conservative
english box everyone's like
that's [ __ ] i'm like what did you
think yeah but again they're gonna
they're going to no foresight
they're gonna it's the farmers aren't
traveling that much
you know what i mean it's like the
people that it's the old but you know
what
i guess england they actually in england
everyone travels everyone has a summer
because
england has no summer so everyone goes
to
the hot spots the nicest in england
overcast
and and 70 degrees fahrenheit have you
ever been yeah
like it uh
i don't i don't mind i don't understand
it
so i don't it's not exot like if i go to
thailand i don't understand it but it's
exotic
right i go to england i don't understand
it really
but it's not exotic so it's not
that like it's a bit like i get like
oliver twist like there's no
[ __ ] anything to tap into
right like churchill i don't even know
what i would what i'm supposed to
i i yeah i don't get from it yeah like
it in
if i go to thailand there's a there's a
in thailand that in the middle of
bangkok there's like this giant river
like
and try saying it it's like crock per
crown or some [ __ ]
and uh naruto knows naruto and um
and there is across the river
there at the mandarin oriental or
sometimes i stayed the mandarin oriental
um because i love saying oriental uh
it's just a great excuse to be racist
and
it's sanctioned um
there is a like a 100 year old bar
it's just you [ __ ] it reeks of
colonialism
and i got to be honest with you it's a
little sexy
it's a little sexy sexy being a colonial
[ __ ]
i'm here in this [ __ ] foreign land
and we tricked them into we we dominated
them
and we won and now
these people are it's a bit of the
[ __ ]
it's just a little sexy in in a way that
england cannot be
do you know what i mean like england
it's like i don't know i know what you
mean it's foreign
i know it's what i'm saying is i'm
admitting to uh the appeal of
colonialism
um which is anti-liberal i mean it's the
the joke i can do is that
i'm against uh colonialism
and then i go to singapore and everybody
speaks english and i'm like well not all
bad
um that's kind of how i feel where it's
like concubines and you know what i mean
like
[ __ ] geishas and all that [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
england has none of that for me it's
just a bunch of white people
right no yeah it's just like most of the
i don't know jimmy carr is there i like
that i know we forgot about
jimmy no no we we text him all the time
i know but i just meant in this
conversation he's the sexiest i don't
there's so many things about england
that i don't understand like
the l show thing
i i just don't liverpool leads yeah i
don't really
have an opinion so but it's
jimmy's there that's nice jamie um
but i don't go to like the west end yeah
um moving on rest in power king
doom mf he's british speaking of
is he um he's english like from
speaking uh i i'm i'm
not 100 sure you're wrong no no i'm not
great um porn in england
born in london moved to long island at a
young age okay
i guess he's english and michael
jordan's from new york
he's just born there um well he lived
there
i don't think he did live there at a
young age
he was kept out of the us for a while oh
good for you yeah
neil tell me another thing i'll deny it
all right um
where's it true couldn't be true that
was nardo talking that was no that was
neil that was neal look
on behalf of nardo i just want to
apologize for what just happened
um is nardo in there and i do a
character uh
hold up oh wait for someone remember how
you
a great uh character
um and a funny idea
and rapping in character is always fun
ray beats and he made great beats he did
an album with
uh feeler brian bryan burton danger
mouse they did it
they did an album together at least one
yeah um
he said a few albums with people i think
danger mouse might have told me that
that uh i don't want to say that because
i don't know if it's true
okay uh somebody wrapped over the beat
for crazy
and it just wasn't right and then ceelo
sang over it and that was like but you
know
give everybody ten million dollars that
happens all the time
no i know but would never do that song
it's not it wasn't there it was ding
ding ding ding
there's not the hook is the thing that
would goes
you go he wouldn't the ceelo part's the
part that you would think right jim
wouldn't do but the dung
didn't know you would
um a great rapper and the fact that he
died two months before it was announced
is so [ __ ] funny and and
funny because in this culture to keep a
death private for two months it's hard
is impossible and
especially him i had a tweet that i
didn't send out but it was like
i haven't mentioned his funeral with
like
old timey sailors talking about like i
knew doom
we used to erase yachts against one
another like he has a lot of like
mystery folklore around like talking
animals
right just great so the fact that he was
able to that it didn't come out
is the i'm going to stick with hilarious
even though
that sounds callous i don't mean like ha
ha you died i just mean
the fact that it was kept private and
then his
girl said it like everyone knew
but it was yeah no one knew no one no
it's sad though because his son died i
think last year
oh really yeah so that's not as funny as
the thing is
for two months maybe it's something to
do with
i don't know yeah might be covered um
but he was great and by the way did you
read the
there was an article in the times about
how
the coveted deaths in africa are low
and they think it might just be because
in africa if your grandma dies you just
bury her in the backyard you don't tell
anyone
so yeah no i read something not in the
times i don't have new york times
but uh if ellie does but yeah
i read that and then some people think
the numbers are just inaccurate
yeah i don't know i i don't know because
brazil's getting eaten up
yeah but then again when ebola was
like ravaging the area people were
reporting it
and so when there's a lot of deaths and
there's a lot of heart reporting because
they were all dying
in the in like at a place
yeah that's one of those things where
you go
is this racism or
true like they don't even you know they
don't
they just bury their granny in the
backyard even saying it i'm like
ah that feels a little bit like savagery
that feels like the guy who enjoys
thailand
um but uh but yeah like and like or
it's just like folksy i met a
woman in the summer that um
worked oh i'm gonna screw it up but
basically she's the head at
usc of um
african health something i don't know
but
it sounded great and she's here she's an
average she's at uc
okay uh but she's the head of their
africa
health africa yeah and she was saying
that
a lot of from her research a lot of the
um
a lot of the reason why africa doesn't
have huge outbreaks
and overrun hospitals and people dying
as much as
other places and people are surprised by
is because of
because of ebola they kept their
resources up
for pandemics it's like murders and all
that [ __ ]
yeah and so they uh taiwan and because
they all got
popped off yeah avian yeah all that [ __ ]
and then they were saying that like
there's a few countries i think senegal
and
a few others that are like the p
pillar of you know what you should be
doing in
these times and there's four they're
just not counting they're just burying
people in the backyard granny
or they're just throwing granny in the
back with the animals
and they let the the the mongooses eat
them
neil calls thailand siam siam
it's the it's what i'm getting at is
like the uh
the hemingway-ness of it like i'm here
in the vehicle
i was in saigon and all the old-timers
joseph [ __ ]
uh what's his name heart of darkness
um dock watches
great perfect street wise you ever see
it
i think i no no the italian one about
no no that's uh that's uh martin
scorsese's mean streets
no not that one there's another italian
mob dock which is not interesting to me
street wise street wise uh it's a
documentary about homeless kids
in the early 80s oh no
and uh it's a real bummer
but it's quite i think it won an oscar
it's like
really well shot like where i'm watching
going like this some of these shots are
a [ __ ] miracle
and all the problems are the exact same
meaning
it's almost the same block in seattle
wow that's
that now still has some homeless people
like it's seattle has so much
homelessness
it's not san francis it's no san
francisco but i actually found it
worse than san francisco okay denver's
got it
pretty bad he's cold please
freezing save your money save and handle
save your money
we would love to have you in venice no
right on my street
yeah with will just got back from hawaii
uh he's wearing a mask yeah he's messed
up
even though he's making the jerk off
signal talking about the mask i'm
talking about the mask he's like [ __ ]
mask my ass
um oh this you know was good
that uh anyone would like it
um midnight family it's on uh it's on
netflix
all in spanish um it is about
um a in the entire
country of mexico there's about
50 ambulances that are sanctioned by the
government or cities
everyone else is private so it's
so they it's truly like
you hear about an accident on the radio
and you haul ass to get there
as an ambulance driver isn't that
similar like a lot of ambulances are
private here
it's so unorganized okay it's so
unorganized that
there's a scene in midnight family where
two ambulances are racing each other
like but they fight for them here too
i i gotta think it's way more organized
here
i'm sure it is i'm sure i just know a
few friends are emts that
um they actually a lot of emts i heard
some tea
whereas okay so basically the
firefighters
almost they'll fight like one or two
fires their whole career
they almost never fight fires
california's a little different because
we have a fire season but most
firefighters
like there's not that many fires in just
the world
so to stay on the budget um because we
see firefighters
a lot you know you see the truck it's
all a little bit of a show
what they do is they they race other
ambulances
to calls or they're all fighting for the
same thing
because all firefighters are actually in
emts as well yeah
so they all go out for it most of the
time of fire when you see a fire truck
it's
never going for a fire so the emts take
away the news
especially it's like you call 9-1-1 for
an ambulance and
like fire trucks show up and you're like
like what's this that's wrong
because i love what you should i love
your thinking but it's the wrong truck
so they're saying that emts here fight
they don't like the firemen
because they're fighting for the same
jobs can somebody who knows about this
right in that's just hearsay so i don't
know yeah
and i gotta think that they fight more
than two fires in their life
just these big ones where it's like
basically to justify the big budget that
they have yeah a lot of people are
firing their whole life
and don't fight really big fights i
don't know
somebody i don't yeah i don't somebody
write in i'm reminded of an old david
tell joke
what uh which is i'm a
volunteer i'm a volunteer fireman
which means at any point i can be called
away
to get drunk with four guys named sully
so [ __ ] that's scary uh it's so funny
okay
but i can imagine it's just worse in
mexico
not to be an [ __ ] it's it's cr i've
never seen two ambulances racing
like that's i i can just tell you like
tokyo
yeah like literally like a like video
game
like you don't have what i have but in
spanish nardo again
naruto nardo come to us nardo loved
nardo can actually understand spanish i
didn't have to turn the the subtitles on
land grab amazon uh prime documentary my
friend danielle recommended
very interesting about
uh did how detroit is how [ __ ] up
detroit is right
and uh some white dude was like hey what
if we just buy
these lots these abandoned lots
and start like a farm
and of course people fought them
tooth and nail just like screaming at
city council meetings
and uh abandoned lots no one was doing
anything yeah
blight blight like urban blight just
garbage
um and people fought him fought and
fought him and now
he he i won't tell you what happens but
he wins
and uh something he's either going to
win or not
um and uh maybe i'm lying wow
maybe i'm iradia
um the but it's [ __ ] interesting that
no it's it's like
helping people is a [ __ ] wasted it's
like they don't
have the people when you're half the
time when you're helping it's like an
ex-girlfriend you said when you were
talking about trying to
explain yeah it's they have a reaction
and you it's like they're having an
epileptic seizure
you know how some epileptics will swing
at you and claw that's what it's like
this guy's trying to like get detroit
and it's [ __ ]
spitting at him and he's like okay he
the whole documentary is going i don't
know why i did
i should have never done this this is a
total waste of time and then
things happen and uh turns out he was
the father
um wait what's up with this girl would
she just have a bad attitude
uh ch the girl i'm talking about um
paranoid and uh but just accuse me [ __ ]
what did you do to try to be like i did
of course
i mean did you do the whole thing or are
you like she got she got mad at me for
i tried for years what'd you get marry
for
wildest uh
i mean and one time she got mad at me
for not texting her back
for like two hours insecure
and i was in a meeting
like a very important potential meeting
right
she knew that and was still like you
know
so when you talk to her you were like
you knew i was in a meeting
yes and and that's why i didn't respond
to you
what was her response to that um
like something along the way i mean if i
can be me about it the meetings
was with will smith it's the first time
i've ever met him okay
and she knew and she was like yeah
just you get with these black comics and
you're like huh
you forget about me
yeah it was because i remember what she
said um
uh they're black dudes or something oh
like someone else
again there are a lot of women who think
anything that you a buddy of mine told
me recently that
his wife doesn't like him talking to me
and i talk to him once a month on the
phone why
and she doesn't like when she because
there are some people that are so
insecure
that any if you're not focused on them
anything you're focused on is a threat
is that the same girl that thought you
enjoyed okay together
no different girl whoa what's going on
i haven't [ __ ] black dudes i guess
it's a [ __ ] black team i'm out here
[ __ ] icons
um uh yeah that was a different
i cannot see okay when
what is your uh red flag now because
obviously
you don't get like i stopped doing three
mics early
because i was like let me just i i if i
don't go home
are you kidding me no it was just so
much bellyache but that's not that long
ago
i'm surprised oh i don't know okay but
i'm saying
i'm surprised you guys because if you
a lot of times bianca if you
as a guy it's very hard
to say
you're gaslighting me i'm not
gaslighting you without sounding like a
gaslighter
so with all with the with the
last five years of uh
women speaking up for ways they're being
oppressed it's
hard to be like hey you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
quit it yeah but what do you do
no shut the [ __ ] up stop it stop
i was here i was here i was here i'm not
talking about
this well you're not she one time said
that i wasn't
honoring her paranoia enough whoa
that's deep yeah that is some deep which
is some deep
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not honoring my
parents basically yeah
what world do you want to live in do you
want to live in paranoia i guarantee you
if she could she would not want to live
like that of course but she didn't know
it was parent
she didn't know you can't she didn't
think it was paranoia at all of course
it all presents as [ __ ]
like an old thing you're cons you're 5g
yeah it's like no yeah so i couldn't
explain to her like i was [ __ ]
talking what are you talking about like
i sometimes i'll get flashbacks to
things she got mad at me before
and it's so it's that that's one of
those things that
it's going to take a long time for it to
go away i'm like oh i'm so [ __ ] mad
at you
um but did
do you think cause that doesn't seem
that long ago uh what
when you see glimpses of that in like do
you have a good
do you have a good detector now now
absolutely
what what is like uh
anything that is uh
because it starts anything that is um
like uh like a antibacterial sees my
life as bacteria that she needs to put
antibacterial on
like areas like oh i don't like you
talking to blank
i i mean again i haven't gotten that
close to anybody since and i never will
no i'm good okay let's say someone saw
your life and was like you need to
organize
you want to organize too so what if
that's not you wouldn't no that's
fine no uh how many nights a week are
you gonna do stand up
whoa yeah no red flag oh they're like
non-negotiables like
yeah like i how
can you take the problem in
relationships i think
i'll speak for my as a man
as a nardo is uh is
that women that i've dated have taken
personally
things that had were pre-existing
like long before like tell me i wanted
it
when i was 10 i wanted to do this yeah
so now you think you're threatened by
this thing
that made you interested in me in the
first place it's just this
weird insecurity and
it's an insecurity and and then
they once they aim it at you you're just
always guilty
yeah of like oh i guess i'm not
if i'm talking in the parking lot at the
comedy store for 10 minutes
you didn't come here right now allie
wong then i guess i am a piece of [ __ ]
yeah some people really with whatever is
going on up there with
certain types of trauma can change the
the the um the
stereotypes in the relationship you're
stereotyped as
a blank yes and i you know and she
didn't think she went through my texts
wow and i was like i without you knowing
her in front of you no without me note
oh and that said you wait who's
so-and-so when i was like
okay now i will say i did that once
and i re i've never done that and i did
it one time well the thing that this is
what a [ __ ] gas lighter she was she's
like well you why'd you listen to me
what do you mean listen to you about her
paranoia wow
are you kidding me that's actually
[ __ ] [ __ ] that is so
cruel yeah yeah to be like i'm gonna
make you do
all these hoops yes wow that's really
stupid
you really you you believed me
that's me yeah no it's it's
sorry no we look mad right now i think
i'm very mad i feel like i
it makes me very much stupid it's just
like i think she's like kind of a
pathological liar
this lady this lady this this one gal
um and uh that was about land grab
apparently that we're
property in detroit went to a grievance
about me
and women if you can believe it i can
get there give me a set up and i will
get
to something about women uh she did say
something very funny one time
um uh one time i mean
she made me get an office because
there's no doors here
oh and outside of here yeah because i
would
talk on my [ __ ] phone again if a girl
says this [ __ ] how do i counter it
without being a [ __ ] total [ __ ]
how about
[ __ ] no she lived here
she moved in you moved into my house
this this house has been right and then
i'm
basically an abusive boyfriend who
wouldn't he wouldn't
it's a blog worthy and then i wanted
there were no doors
is that maybe you filling in that like
yes and no because i'm like what's the
no what if you just were like
maybe she needed a good no [ __ ] deal
with it
again it's easy for women to say no
[ __ ] but
as ally wong did the joke like it's
women are very good at making things
unpleasant oh yeah so exactly so again
i can f how i can't fight i just [ __ ] it
all right i'll get an office
in her one time me and rocker on the
phone and uh
got off she only heard my side and she
yelled
why do you guys even date women that's
pretty funny that's funny
i will say though in her defense when
you are on the phone
everything's well everything nothing
really can continue in this place
yeah because you're like and then she i
know it's like
because there's high ceiling i got to
fill the room i don't even want to
um yeah so i guess i'm a [ __ ] but also
there are no doors there's curtains
there's a beatles documentary there's a
five-minute preview of the beatles
documentary directed by peter jackson
that is a re i mean let it be
there was a document i don't know just
let it be your abbey road right let it
be
the the movie there's a documentary
about it right
and this is the footage from that peter
jackson's making another one
documentary and that's what the there's
a if you have apple tv
uh which you may it's hard to know um
you may
test the positive um hundreds of people
know
but one in every two person has is test
positive for apple tv doesn't even know
it
um you could be a carrier uh it's five
minutes it's [ __ ] great and you
the beatle the beatles are so goddamn
great
and i'm i whatever i
the interesting thing about the
documentary is john lennon
at two points like walks and you realize
like oh i've never really seen john
lennon walk
oh there's a thing where he like
traipses across the thing and like does
a twirl and you're like
i don't think i've ever seen him walk
before if you think about it like where
would you have seen him walk i've seen
him walk
where uh i did a deep dive in yoga ono
stuff
mm-hmm and they're like walking together
oh okay people are like he's like it's
like
things or photos or he's on stage or
it's like mostly
what did you want to know about yoko i
did i didn't
have a good understanding of how she
broke up a band she's just a girlfriend
and then you kind of do need to do a
deep dive to understand how
it was just more and more of a thing and
then this
music they had no [ __ ] boundaries was
their problem
dude they just had no they were so like
one
yeah just immediately and if you're in
the band it's she didn't break them up
but if you're in the band you're like i
don't [ __ ] want to make [ __ ]
i think they overdid it if you watch the
documentary there's so many [ __ ]
people around
yeah that that is what happens
in bands it's like the fact that number
nine
is a track is that is that hers
number nine yeah she's it's not good oh
no of course not
well she's not in the beatles there you
have a good reason he's not one and then
some of his
music with her it's like woman oh yeah
well it's just it's uh it's it's like
it's of its time like the primal scream
and like mother
just all that like uh but i did like
he made some his solo shit's
great in a lot of ways some of it's
great some it's not
okay yeah no i just you know what it is
it's interesting yoka owner is
interesting
she's like too interesting almost so
everything was weird and
you just go down a rabbit hole yeah the
whole thing seemed kind of weird
and then i'm like i don't yeah it was
just interesting it was just really
i went down and then there's a lot of
videos of them walking
oddly enough to and from places
um the uh
yeah that's great and
i sent it to trayvon and roy or i was
like you guys watch this
and they're like cor it's like such a
funny like who's the black guy
there's one black guy in the trailer and
they're like that was their only
question
and it was billy preston um and then
there's another doc
i'm i'm watching streetwise and this doc
singled out
not about me and chris hardwick's early
work with jenny mccarthy wow
uh about single women around the world
and it's pretty cool i don't know if you
started it yet but it's it's on
i i watched it on canopy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can see the library one
so i like canopy like the best it can be
unlimited like criterion but
well they're all unlimited what do you
mean oh i mean
they um every month they take out and
put more
so you really get like a like a
huge stream of
i don't know independent foreign it's
like stuff that you go where the [ __ ] is
that showing and
a lot of times on cannabis you can find
the most specific
no one's watched type of movie yeah
which i like so i just
i and it has almost all the criterion
yeah it has
and then you've got some jonas in there
oh there's unsingled out
um the janice yes
somebody jesus romero made a joke
jonas the logo is like the greek guy uh
somebody said that clay thompson
looks like the pbs logo he does a thesis
ramirez
they also wrote a joke for a thing i
connected them with uh you know jesus
romero
yeah a little i um
um the uh my god the
oh that uh kevin durant so arms for so
long he can
uh tie his shoes without bending over
just a good kind of mother joke jesus
don't know who wrote it but
good job guys good job good job
um let's do some emails will it's time
hi blankie that's a mix of kneeling okay
anyway
so i have a question from france about
anger management not the movie
but the situation i have an example
i'm living in a really small apartment
in paris
with my girlfriend suddenly her friends
come for a visit
unspecified amount of time and after
eight days i feel like either i'm gonna
have to kick them out which i really
don't want to do
it's not in my nature or i have to
um really sacrifice a lot of private
space
so i'm kind of stuck and i get angry how
would you deal with that situation
and have you ever felt like you need to
deal with anger management issues thanks
a lot love you guys bye
have i hello have you listened to the
podcast
um that doesn't seem anger management
that yeah that's your that's your that's
you
you a [ __ ] the quote bianca for not
putting your [ __ ] foot down and
making it so you don't get any [ __ ] for
months but you put your foot down
uh because whether they admit it or not
women
extort behavior from us in exchange for
sex
now i'd like to speak to nardo now
um i've taken a class
like recently was it good no damn
it was mandated by court so i excited
did you take a class
what did you do to get a court man no i
i
i ruled against myself and said you need
to go to an angry mansion
oh the court didn't oh you went to the
court mandated anger management
correct those aren't good correct
um there are some books i've read a
bunch of books about it
that the what i the main thing i learned
was
um you get angry most of the time
because you're being invalidated
that's most of it is like you're [ __ ]
ignoring
me and my needs that's where most anger
comes from
so once you know that you can work back
anything you're mad about it's just
you're being inconsiderate
sometimes it's being uh like
completely ignoring you like completely
ignorant of you like
um but once you know that
then you can kind of work backward but
it's so hard it's
changing is the hardest it's the worst
[ __ ] um
it's just the hardest thing in the world
it's truly the hardest thing in the
world to change
yeah um but especially someone who's
quick to anger
that quick to anger a lot of times is
learned
especially when it's out of nowhere type
of anger i don't know
well one of the things in one of the
books i read was that
it's a lot of people that are angry have
never
seen things resolved peacefully yeah
i might the amount of yellow i mean
yelling was
options one through three in my house
yell then yell different than yell
[ __ ] then yeah i mean just like
[ __ ] your house would be quiet for some
reason oh
loud house yeah ten people 10 people
loud house naruto say
10 people no uh
yeah it's yell it's so cut so the idea
of
a mutually respectful resolution
isn't even possible yeah to most people
yeah i've dated one person in particular
that
did not have those didn't have
the skills to conflict resolve
at all without it getting so
terrible and it felt like a train
that was gonna come no matter what i did
no matter if i was
gentle nice equally as aggressive
no matter what it was a train that was
gonna pull the decision whether i liked
it or not
like the anger because it just had to do
like
i don't know it had to live out its life
cycle my brother
kevin jogs every day or ex rides his
bike or jogs every day to quote get the
brennan out of him
kevin um that's very funny
yeah like it's but that's like he
yeah i i books i mean and it is
it is very interesting and it's also
i think men have an issue which is we're
never
shown leaders who don't scream
so coaches military
yeah it's all that's part of the that's
like the main tool
yeah so
and we're just barely
out of those woods it's only 20 20. we
just started reading
i mean in human history it's all of its
blink of an eye
it's like yelling was fine up until very
recently
yes and it might come back
it might never know sometimes it comes
but sometimes it's useful like chris was
saying like when he did
he was like yeah sometimes yelling is
like you know
i feel like hughes is yelling wisely
steve kerr
the the warriors coach especially when
they were good like
where he would get he would like break a
clipboard over
because he's not bobby knight right he's
not seething all the time so that it's
not so entertaining right he's not he's
not seething all the time so that it is
like
oh this must be worthwhile if he's
if you're giving it away every [ __ ]
time you feel something
or you're discontent yeah it just
becomes like
okay it doesn't it's it's
now the question is is it persuasive
that's the that's ultimately they're i
think it's persuasive maybe
effective i don't it depends right well
yes there's
if you're um uh if you're trying to make
a marine
yeah go ahead and yell but
a lot of times yelling doesn't i mean
people aren't going to come they're not
going to be forthcoming towards you
you know it's just not it's just not
it's not the most effective way to keep
no one wants to deal with all that [ __ ]
so if if it's effective to
hide everything that will make you yell
fine i'm sure it's effective but most of
the time it doesn't
also sometimes in work situations
even on sets i'm com i'm baffled that we
allow people to behave like that just
because they're a boss
well that's not like you can hit it's
always men
of course it's always been but uh and if
it's women a lot of times it's like
there's a culture there
yeah but it's not like we allow our boss
to be
she's a [ __ ] i want to make that clear
the man is a leader and the woman is a
[ __ ]
no okay uh but it's not like we're
accepting of your boss hitting you or
it's not no it is verbal hitting i mean
it's
it's verbally yeah and we allow it i
mean how is
i also think every time i've been on set
when people like it was a really good
project to work on they're saying that's
that thing that [ __ ] eight hours or
14 hours you want to have like so and so
yell at you
right or it was pleasant is what they're
saying it was actually
pleasant and not a lot of things are
pleasant but as a director are you
do you get snippy do you make it yeah uh
but
like less so i i'm not i would never
yell
sometimes you kind of sometimes you
gotta like goose the operation a little
bit like
let's go right like a little something
for sure
otherwise you're gonna get [ __ ] over a
little bit by a bunch of dudes without
getting without
uh belittling them you're kind of like
guys come on
you know what man so you just give him
hit him with a let's go every once in a
while
um i used to do a thing on my jeremy
piven
car movie i did a thing every day where
i gave away an mvp
trophy every day and it's the best thing
i did
it was it worked great every day and
then
the last day i mean i gave one to like a
pa one time they cried
and they were just like piece of [ __ ]
like trophies yeah rinky-dink
people just want to be singled out at
uh as uh if i may uh singled out
as a uh as important they just want to
be acknowledged
um i know i think one of my i'm not sure
which parent but somebody
there was another manager in a different
department and when she took over
as manager she put a index card in
everyone's cubicle
and would award a gold star these are
adult
engineers yeah and everyone loved
getting the gold star if i ever like a
tv show or something again
i'm gonna give envelopes out
to like people that if someone i always
tell seth like
give alex baze the writer
just give him 15 grand in cash for
christmas
and he's like what what are you talking
like just [ __ ] give them the
it's you can't you'll never
forget it yeah never forget it like
george lopez gave me five grand in cash
one time
for a show i'm still talking about it
you love george lopez yes you'll never
know a decade later
i'm still like whatever don't well
he's a spanish brother uh he's naruto's
ombre
um uh yeah just give just
give so drake took me 200 and i
will i will drake defend him
drake apparently there was something
with the strippers and something writer
there were a bunch of writers on the
espys or something drake hired a bunch
of strippers and gave them all
knots of money the writers to like
[ __ ] cash money talks
um so so yeah i don't
that but and there are just read an
anger book they're
they're none of them are bad also in
paris the apartments are like shoe boxes
but they're so romantic oh i know we got
to preserve the culture
[ __ ] you on balcony um so
i think just i mean i don't know have a
conversation with your woman and be like
yo they gotta go
yeah the people made us some songs
yeah let's hear some songs these are
this is trouble what is this uh
he's doing the christmas [ __ ] outfit
he gave us all
ear covered
under do it do less
they know they know wait is that the
same person like yell but that's where
you want to yell
is this easy right and the winner
old caribbean woman i mean he's got he's
it's okay he could get yeah just speed
it up
just make it for three seconds but this
isn't eric johnson there's another guy
but yeah no one is hurting that's the
trouble in the winner's circle austin
ford
oh got it sorry just make it a shorter
yeah
well you can do that speed it up patch
it down
bop it spin it goodbye you've got merry
[ __ ] miss and happy neal field
whether our parents were good at
parenting considering how bad slash
good their parents were is the subject
of a short funny poem by a
tall serious poet from the second half
of the 20th century named philip larkin
uh he seems to have reached the same
conclusion that neil did regarding kids
philip larkin if you don't know
is you know when um four runnings in a
funeral
yeah that you you know how everybody
keeps doing the poem
at the same yeah it's that's his oh
that's he's a
he writes bang and [ __ ] he's like the
only like
he's like not shel silverstein he's like
a popular poet
but it's that you go oh yeah that's good
right it's not
like brothers and sisters
um it is a race issue of course uh
1971 this be the verse is the name of it
they [ __ ] you up your mom and dad
they may not mean to but they do they
fill you with the faults they had
and add some extra just for you do i
have to keep doing this
i don't like do it wait one more time
but they were [ __ ] up in their turn
by fools and old style hats and coats
who half the time were
soppy stern and half at one another's
throats
man hands on misery to man it deepens
like a coastal shelf
get out as early as you can and don't
have kids
yourself that was really good neil
thanks rotten rhymes
um phil parker everybody phillip largan
go see him
go download his podcast go see him i'm
sure he has a podcast go listen to it
it's all rhyming
uh no he's he writes good [ __ ] um and by
i say that because i know two of his
poems and that was one of them and the
other one was
rooted and the other ones from four
runners in the funeral the
which made me cry out tear up every time
i watched it which was twice
20 years ago goodbye hold up de la buena
although i somewhat agree with bank's
decision not to buy
goodwill because of their business
practice toward its employees the store
does help families that can't afford to
buy at full price
during high school we bought most of our
clothing there out of necessity now
i think the prices are comparable to
marshalls and ross depending on where
the store is located
people buy it goodwill for environmental
reasons sometimes
something about diverting fabric from a
landfill
and to be friendly and unique or to be
trendy and unique i can't read because
my eyes leak i got some oil in my eye
but i could be full of [ __ ] actually
that philip larkin poem really [ __ ] me
up
so in the end i guess it comes down to
the treatment of people versus trying to
do good towards the environment
good point and then there's another one
um there's a bossier one that we'll get
into
goodbye um you've got mail
okay here it is uh howdy i do finance
consulting for
non-profit organizations private
foundations and government funding
agencies with the leading
consulting firm in the space i've i'm a
grown-up
have worked exhaustively in the
nonprofit sector have
have an enormous amount of highly
specialized experience and i'm a leader
and expert in this field
measurably by many accomplishments
despite this neil i can't
i i'm confident you and your listeners
can understand the following just fine
uh basically he said unfortunately a
prevailing
perspective over many decades has been
that the key indicator telling
prospective donors of a given non-profit
organization
is an effective one worthy of their gift
is the ratio of which
that organization spends on its programs
to what it invests in its overhead
uh this has uh incentivized non-profit
organizations to
chronically under-invest in the
necessary support basically saying we
were
[ __ ] dead ass wrong about what those
are um
fortunately smarting payments people did
the research and have demonstrated that
there is precisely zero relationship
between
how effective an organization is making
an impact on its mission
and what it spends on overhead not an
ounce
in fact your beloved rating sites like
charity navigator guide star etc have
issued apology letters to nonprofits and
donors
recognizing the harm their prior
fallacious guidance has contributed to
and caused um then he goes on to say
uh so how how how and what what what
about being dead ass wrong
this guy's very condescending we'll get
to that in a second
um i encourage you to amplify the
transformative work being done
to this to right this wrong or if
nothing else
to not like share the next post you see
crowing about
organizations that oh so worthy because
100 of every dollar raised goes directly
to funding programs
given to organizations with missions you
care about doing work you think is good
don't compel organizations to start
themselves for dollars
uh so as to be too haggard to do work
you care about as well
uh thanks for the jokes p.s if you want
some
if you want to write some of the harm
your words may have caused you could
send any of the winner's circle
any any winner circlers with questions
about
giving my about giving my way so i can
help them do good and a
fulfill everyone's fantasies of falling
into charlie rose over here yeah exactly
um do it neil
yeah this guy writes on and on and on i
want to be clear
that we do not work for you i want to be
clear to everyone listening to this
podcast
we don't work for you we work for anchor
and we work for
[ __ ] spotify we work for
no we don't have time
anchor writes and says neil shut up
i do it i just love that it's like tell
all your winner circles
give send them my way do it neil
you think i'm [ __ ] bringing this up
in like a dinner you [ __ ]
egomaniac i know only
a man with a bigger ego than yours it's
hard to do right
this guy's got some great ideas about
government and and um
virology well okay let's give him that
yes
i believe him and uh in the spirit of
uh recognizing a commanding officer he's
the commanding officer when it comes to
charity and i guess we should all just
give
to the charity we believe in and
and hope that they do the right thing
with our money
wow we just got to hope that they do the
right thing because apparently we can't
ask questions
i'm not saying you can't ask questions
buddy we're not going to read the next
letter this one took too long
that was yeah no and it felt very
hostile it's just like we're just
waiting
people are trying to be fun hostile but
it doesn't
that's like negan save it you know when
people think they're being fun and
flirty and it's like
you're mean yes uh you some people can't
do it
here's a good one hey neil in the lovely
bank last week you said that ellen was
very good at what she does i agree and
that she was unlike any other comedians
don't agree at all
this isn't meant to say that she's
intentionally ripping someone off but i
feel that if you study most communities
you can execute their lineage in this
case ellen is a direct
committee to senate bob newhart you're
absolutely correct
and um i think i what i meant was she's
not doing anything
like people that are doing it now no
what i thought you said was that
her voice is so specific oh right yes
well
there's the other thing i've i've
learned reading letters people don't
[ __ ] listen
and if i get one more dm going what was
that website you mentioned
there's a [ __ ] rewind button on your
thing do you think i'm
dming pot the daily going what did you
get
the [ __ ] audio's there i'm gonna
rewind it and
find it and i'm gonna be kind
um yes so i may not have even said this
but if he wants to
feel like he got one over no don't make
it weird
no he he's right right of course but i
don't know
that i said that i think you're saying i
said that she doesn't sound like anyone
you said she her voice is her the pitch
of her voice
yeah doesn't sound like anyone and then
you go on to say other complimentary
things but i think you know what
yeah you got me both just like robin
williams was linked to john of the
winners and everybody black
born between 1965 and 1985 but the
handful
with an exception of a handful is doing
richard pryor also true
um yes
cool i was going to add some insight
there and i'm going to back away
okay i would be hurting
hurting myself don't do it and others
um prior did do cosby for five years
though
so you just said it yeah but the i
there's a dirtier part that i'm not
okay um uh
cue wait we just did that um
that guy did two pps's
and then added more links [ __ ] this
guy never
is never ending goodbye um this guy
don't stop
uh
okay so then this comes down to
you've got mail sorry
was just listen to discussion on comedic
expertise
comedic expertise uh while i think you
pulverized the opposition over the last
couple episodes
and via your twitter karate my
award-winning twitter karate
regarding all the dunning-kruger
comedians out there there was one point
you made that bianca disagree with that
i think merits a bit more discussion
paraphrasing you made the point that
guys are more likely to think they can
be as good of a comedian as you
uh but wouldn't think that of any number
of other comedians bianca disagreed in
retort you know
that men will make these comedy comments
to you but probably wouldn't do
to rogan because he'll pummel them um
not not at this not at this tax property
um he will he'll no now he can't do
anything
no uh i think it um i think it might be
even more basic than him pummeling them
in a word style you your writing chops
are indisputable
and because your writing is so tight
three mics was amazing largely because
of its simplicity solid premises
perfectly written calmly delivered
unique special but because of the
delivery style and the curt language you
make it look easy
contrast that with guys like rogan kevin
joe and dane they all look like they're
working their balls off on stage
their timing uh of physicality energy
and punch lines
along with the sweat pouring off of them
makes them seem more untouchable
almost exclusively because of the
mannerisms and straight delivery style i
suspect many men out there think they
can replace you
marin or even dave more easily than they
could burr sebastian coe
i guess it's coy or fluffy um
obviously um everyone mentioned here is
untouchable but anyone other than
an exceptional talent but i think that
your style gives people falsehood
i this guy's absolutely right i think
he's right too
convinced yeah absolutely right this was
like
rarely does someone come up with a
better argument for me
about myself but i'm like yeah that's
exactly because i seem laconic
they go wow dave
like isn't dave can vary speed
dave can do like five different things
yeah which most people can't
no um so he can do
like long setups
and then he can be like [ __ ] i
don't have that yeah
i don't have the other thing but what i
am going to start doing is spraying
myself
down with sweat baby oil before i go on
and of course i did [ __ ] the stool in
the last half and you did this the the
sex move the samsonite yeah
if you did more i remember when you did
that bit
and i i thought to myself yes
neil pretending to have sex with
somebody
lord if you're listening make me a
suitcase
you know way anyways so when i remember
seeing that i remember thinking
neil does not do state uh actos
ever because i noticed that but the
thing is i do
they're just not i don't go like you
don't remove them
also not true when my
comedy central special i moved moved
into act out
it's a it's a vigorous act out you don't
do
movie action i don't do i don't run
across the stage no no not that stage
but
in your would you say in your comedy
your act outs
do they take a lot of space no that's
what i'm saying like i don't
run i don't like i do do things like
girls like this and then she's and then
i jump and did it which
if if dave does it you're like oh my god
i
because i'm laconic nothing i do
it's like where people go i don't know
you dance
and why not i don't know i just didn't
think you could dance
the samson i act out was the i remember
thinking
huh looks different he's moving on he's
moving
more than he's gotten into him he must
have upped his toes again
or you'll do the it's not safe that that
that's a good one that's a voice one
that's a voice one but you
it it's uh it all goes towards
women walking i do women kneeling
i do women uh damn girl that titty gives
bananas i'm moving as i do that
i'm i'm uh you look like you got
leadership skills i'm walking on that
um i rap
when i say the n word i'm i'm literally
rapping and moving
but because i it doesn't seem like
yeah it really doesn't yeah it seems
like i'm standing still
like not moving because it's um
it's like a metabolism thing meaning
it's like i'm
you know those guys are like 105 beats
per minute
and i'm like 95 beats per minute okay
and
it's hard to even when it's fast there
are hip-hop songs that are high
beats per minute that don't sound like
high beats for a minute i can't explain
it like no i know
it sounds if something's like more
acoustic you wouldn't think
it's high energy but if it's fine if
narrator
if it's [ __ ] fiddle you're like what
in the [ __ ]
the thing is ian is
similar yeah and no one i don't think
people are going up to ian and being
like i could do what you do
oh well they're not going up to him but
they
cuz he's black yeah maybe yeah maybe
you can't logically get there you can't
get like there's so
with that machine you can't get there
they're so ian yeah that's like oh that
came that's
i just i don't know is it the energy
thing because there are
no energy the energy it's the energy
that's another comic that's
similar energy i remember a tell used to
always say like you and morgan murphy
are similar and i would think like me
and morgan murphy are not similar at all
but i don't know and then there are
people that think
me and michelle wolf are similar now
they would go are you guys relate
anytime one of those on the daily show
are you guys related and i don't know
what it is i think it's
a beats per minute thing it's like how
tightly wound are you
yeah like how quickly is your thing
kevin's thing is this
chris's is more like yeah and dave's is
amazing he's doing
hand gestures right yeah sorry sorry is
that does that not work on an audio
podcast no i don't think so
um and kevin's tightly kevin's tight
dave chris zigzag zigzag
um and dave is dave can evan floyd
yeah yeah he could do a lot um but he's
right like that rogan seems like and
wrote
joe yells almost the entire time and
it's happening
he goes from like like
and then he's calm and there's a so
yeah even when i yell
it doesn't seem like i'm yelling meaning
i did
like there was for my comedy central
hour when i was on the road my
mandates were like hold the mic further
away from your mouth
so you have to be loud and move
make sure you move yeah you have the
most energy on
three mics i feel like no no really
no i had no energy i mean i couldn't
have energies
because rock gave me the note like you
got it whatever space you're in you have
to stay in that space
oh so you had so i couldn't the notes
that when i'm telling them sorry snap
stories i'm in the middle
i meant the you're like random
comedy central ones like i think there's
one you're wearing a red i don't
remember but i know that
the netflix one i had would have had
more in
the the communities of the world the
stage was [ __ ] tiny though
really so once you're on the station
like [ __ ] but it is regardless of
stage or three mics or not it is a lot
of
reflection of your personality i mean
yeah
that absolutely but it's uh
like base amount in my voice
and really deep voice and
uh and like
speed of talking how comfortable are you
though working on would you work on that
would you try to
do more constantly what do you think
this thing's for
i have to get myself into moving more
when i go back i did a spot
three months ago and i had um
it's the guy who used to open for dalia
irish guy
oh oh yeah he looks like irish it was uh
it was michael and ochi i had i gave him
my phone
and anytime i wasn't smiling or moving i
let him shock me oh my god hilarious
and it was [ __ ] hilarious can i shock
you
yeah i want to shock you i mean it's
more did you not get shocked
no when you need to see what it's like
i'm like let me shock you okay
this is of course the it's of course
the uh pavlok three hold on
ladies and gentlemen not a sponsor but
we do work for them
will is so funny
idiot purchase um it looks almost like
uh what were those watches
like an iphone watch yeah okay
oh that was weird oh my my toes are
tingling
i don't like this do it again
oh my god it's so straight it's like
sixty percent that was forty inches oh
give me give me all that [ __ ]
i know b
that's good that's so weird
it feels like uh a static shock yeah
yeah but worse it's not
it's not pleasant or unpleasant it's
closer to unpleasant
you ever see those gag gifts where it's
like you want a gum
and you take it and it's like yeah it's
like that kind of yeah
but for a split second i did a show
where i just let it i had to shock me
once a minute
the last show i did in san diego wow
that's some catholic [ __ ] dude i know
you're like the guy on uh was it the da
vinci code where he's like
doing that [ __ ] in the thigh i saw that
i
couldn't believe it explain it to the
people in the da vinci code there's like
a weird [ __ ] psychotic
like like yeah like
seminary student and he the term
self-flagellate is it's a term i was
aware of which is like you whip yourself
emotionally this was an actual this guy
had a cat of nine tails with
spikes on the end of it and he would
whip himself
and when i saw it i really i felt seen
as they said for the first time for the
first time um
that once a minute and it's like neil i
don't know how often because i i don't
know what do you want
to do what do you want to accomplish
more with this
like in a hostage situation i want to
make it so that i just do it
automatically you have not smiled much
in this podcast
well you wouldn't either if you were
sitting across from me
where's nan nardo but i didn't do it for
the podcast i will
i literally thought i should next time i
mean do you want it to be just your
onstage persona do you want it to affect
you i mean i would like to be smiling
more
it's a huge benefit that's why i have
as my screen saver i'll put it up right
now oh you changed it yeah it was just
like
me and it says oh that's
not what i thought seem nice because
that is more important
than being nice doesn't this all feel a
little
torturous towards yourself just like
come on smile
look nice remember what we you know it's
like this
yes of course but i'm
frustrated by
i if i can write
jokes for the legends
what's keeping me from being a legend
myself and that is
likability okay that's the inherent
difference between me
chris dave ellen well now
now do they shock themselves no but
chris
used to rehearse in front of a [ __ ]
mirror before
bring the pain he had mirrors set up in
his basement and a mic stand
but that probably wasn't about
likability
yeah it was it's just like rehearsing
did you rehearse it was
it was not like martin buried him and he
couldn't follow him okay
because he didn't move he just used to
scout the audience question
yes a few episodes back we were talking
about
what skills and abilities you're you can
work on and
but you kind of we were kind of chicken
and the egging it
like you probably have to be born with
it
to a certain degree so if you're working
so hard i mean i remember a few years
ago you
trying you did that you read this book
on being charming yeah
and we're like remember people's names
and you made a chart of everyone's names
and
you didn't remember people's names well
bianca you mean the chart that i was
studying the other day
i'm recall redoubling my efforts okay
okay keith heard you're going through it
okay um
do you think maybe being that type of
likeable this
universally likable is not in your
wheelhouse well that's why i brought my
niece up earlier
because i because feel like as a person
yes but it's a it's like i want to be a
widow
it's [ __ ] weird and funny yeah um
and then i'm embarrassed to admit it
publicly right
but i you i want to try to get better
and i don't i'm not going to get to
[ __ ] dave
ellen level or chris level but i can
i can i'll get somewhere i'm reaching
for the stars and
hitting the moon all right
i believe it i mean i don't know what to
do i like i want to get better as a
comedian and i want to
i want to get uh
more appealing but the thing is
what i'm saying is you're kind of
curmudgeony
you're like part curmudgeon part really
sensible though
because i mean like marin not [ __ ]
smiling and he is though
marin you want to talk about act outs oh
yeah
he's falling in his last special [ __ ] he
would have
walked out of right five years earlier
yeah
you just have to it's like you're just
more
uh open because i'm not opposed to it
it's like you say i'm silly i just
am not okay i see so you want to like
bring out what's there
in like a pleasant way because i'm just
like i like you i don't
want you to be like not gonna be
different yeah okay you know what i mean
like they're not going to be
i'm not going to be like and i'm going
to write about the morning
all my jokes are going to be about
[ __ ] or the outside
in the morning and massages
etc would you be good if someone gave
you a challenge like write a joke about
this
i the last time blake did stand up i
swear to god i wrote him 10 minutes and
10 minutes wow to the point where i was
like dude you're [ __ ]
an idiot that you can
do this that like
i so i i've never done it but i've gone
like i've wanted to give myself prompts
of like
you're speaking to a dental convention
tonight right just
go because i would be able to but i it's
hard to get there
right all right we this is too long
really long
um sorry guys so the guy who
challenged who said he could do stand-up
wrote and apologize
oh wait say it real quick um
yeah he said please don't share but he
also put us through too much for us
dude we're not listening to him anymore
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna blow up
okay dude but he just paraphrased
basically
he felt like an [ __ ] a sister told
him he was an [ __ ]
and his only defense was i have no idea
what i'm talking about and for the most
part you're obviously right
now if you think i was suggesting anyone
could do this i'm absolutely not
99.99999 are trash
they're the kind of people who think
they're funny because they can give a
best man speech or can quote the
hangover
um this guy he won a couple cop stand up
competitions early in life
okay then he moved to l.a got robbed
robbed which is already very funny the
day he got already funny
and then ended up in options trader
that's one of the things this is where
you just get into crazy thing i write
so he's been doing it in his garage he
shot a 57
minute special in his garage and then he
writes it was quite amazing there was a
lot of promise
maybe 14 strong minutes since then i've
recorded about another 11 hours of
material
which is like you're a maniac if you
think
it goes to what you said you're like i'm
not going to put the audience through an
hour
why so he does an hour for 14 minutes
and he goes i can do an hour
what are you talking about even this guy
thinks his even his apology is insane
but thank you for writing thank you but
thank you thank you you [ __ ]
maniac um and also go do an open mic
when the world opens up again just do
open mics yeah just do open like that's
how everybody when people want to get
around that it's like
you go oh i want to go to the store you
got to go
on a weekend i'll bet i don't care if
you're going to bet
the problem is everybody to whoever
listening every single person thinks
that they're the
funniest dude they have a story about
how they are funny here they're
wherever so just go throw your hat in
with everybody
everyone kind of sucks but you'll you'll
get a feel
of like oh maybe this is something i do
or you will get a feel of like
yeah and then you do
give it another decade yeah keep doing
it and you'll like dave started when he
was 14.
yeah he became dave jabel in capital
letters
15 years later so
like and he's in the hall of fame
so ellen [ __ ] forever chris for
like it takes everyone a decade um
so i don't want
i don't want to talk anymore i'm just
saying i'm so sick of talking
is nardo sick of talking
no all right goodbye everybody